Alright,
here we go.
Four,
three,
two.
Hello Bill.
Hi,
what's going on man?
I am very excited to be here.
I'm excited to have you here.
Excellent.
The social leap.
Yes.
What's the social leap?
I'll tell you all about it.
Please do.
Okay.
So,
um,
the story that I want to tell is
basically how we got here,
how are we became human?
And so that story begins about six or 7
million years ago when our ancestors
left the rain forest.
And so the question is why would they
leave and how would they survive once
they left?
And,
and that's what the social leap.
So it takes a second to get it all out
there.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
So here's the story.
So if you look back about 7 million
years,
our ancestors and chimps,
we had a common ancestor at about that
point in time six or 7 million years
ago,
and that common ancestor,
we don't know exactly what it looked
like,
but it was from all we can tell,
it was awfully close to today's chimps
and so there,
if you look at chimps today,
you can get a pretty good sense of what
life was like then.
And chimps today are really interesting.
They're basically at the top of the food
chain in the rain forest there,
super fast up in the trees,
super athletic,
and they.
Because they travel in groups,
even amazing tree climbers like leopards
won't try to attack them in trees.
It's just they're too dangerous,
too fast.
But if you look at a chimp on the
ground,
it can't even lock.
It's nice.
It's kind of cute little stumbling along
thing.
And then the question is why would an
animal that runs the show in the canopy
leave the rain forest for the Savannah
and then how it survived.
Once I did that and that's.
That's the story of this book.
And then how that manifests itself to
where we are today.
So really my goal,
I'm a psychologist,
I want to understand why we are the way
we are.
And so in trying to figure that out,
I said,
well,
let's take a look back all the way to
our common ancestors and seed some of
the key events and how they might've had
an influence on how we are today.
So the first question is why would we
leave the trees right here we are,
we're dominant position where we're food
on the ground.
Why would we ever take that risk?
And the basic story there is the great
African Rift Valley,
I'm not sure if you're familiar with
that at all,
but basically it runs down from up at
the Red Sea down to the coast of
Mozambique.
And you can think of it like a
geographic zipper.
You know,
all the world's sits on these tectonic
plates and sometimes they crash into
each other like,
uh,
how Indians smashing into Asia and
creates amylase.
Sometimes they literally tear apart and
Africa's tearing apart at the great
African Rift Valley.
So that plate that has Somalia and
Ethiopia,
Tanzania,
Kenya,
that's moving off to the lower right,
the rest of Africa is moving off to the
upper left and I got no idea why it's
been going on for quite a while,
but one of the consequences that is that
the east Africa starting to rise up
slowly bit by bit and when it rises up,
the rainforest dry out and so basically
what you have is a situation where our
ancestors were on the east side of that
Rift Valley and it started to dry out
and now they're in a situation where
they've got this great lifestyle,
their dominant position,
but now they're pushed.
They're forced out onto the ground
increasingly more and more because
there's more and more ground and less
and less rain forest.
And so how do they survive that?
What do they do in order to make that
work?
And this is a what,
what period of time is this?
How many millions of years ago,
six or seven,
six or seven.
Does this coincide with the when?
When was the jump of the human brain
size?
We're doubling.
We'll get to that.
So it's a super interesting question
about why that happened as well.
So basically if you track us across the
next 3 million years,
how did our ancestors survive when
they're basically chimpanzees on the
open savannah and you can get a hint of
how they did it because there's one
chimpanzee group that does live on the
Savannah in Senegal and they,
they show some differences between
themselves and other chimps that
traveling slightly larger groups.
They share more nicely with each other,
which is interesting.
That's kind of a human trait as well.
And uh,
they also avoid open space,
like they're just kind trying to stay
near the trees as much as possible.
And so,
and if you look at other eight,
they're not aids,
but other primates that are on the
Savannah,
baboons,
they're only monkey,
so they're not as sharp as chimpanzees
are,
but they have a similar strategy,
large groups to try to protect
themselves and lots of eyes to look out
for predators.
And they do fine on the savannah.
And so what I suspect happened is for
the first few million years,
basically what you've got is this chimp
like animal that's kind of skirting the
edges of Savannah,
nowhere near the top dominant position
they used to be and just kind of
noodling around.
And that takes,
I suspect,
that takes us for about the first three,
three and a half million years.
And if you look at who we are,
then we're Australopithecus afarensis.
So it's,
if you looked at one of them,
you'd think it belongs in a zoo.
It looks almost like a chimpanzee.
And so a chimp brain and answer the
first part of your question is about 380
grams.
And australopithecines brain is about
450 grams.
So 3 million years of evolution and all
we've got four to 70 grams.
So why do we get so smart?
Why do we take off in the next few
million years?
And what is it that Australopithecus did
that,
that helped us survive?
And why do I call that the social late?
That's all kind of tied together.
And the basic story is it by this point
Australopithecus has become bipedal and
we can talk about how that happened,
if you'd like.
And so because they're bipedal,
their waste is now stretched out their,
um,
their musculature.
Like if you look at Chimpanzee Pecs,
they aim upward because of course chimps
climbing all the time.
I'm Australopithecus is more lateral
like we are.
We're basically completely lateral
because things are side to side as far
as we're concerned.
It's harder to climb a tree,
but it's a whole lot easier to do a lot
of other things.
And um,
we have much more limber shoulder,
we have much more limber wrist,
all that sort of thing.
And a lot of that was in place by
Australopithecus.
So once they became bipedal,
they gained a lot of these qualities.
And then the question is why do those
qualities matter?
Well,
the,
if you watch a chimpanzee throw,
it's terrible at it,
even though they're stronger than you
and I are pound for pound by a sizable
margin.
When they throw their inept,
they can't aim very well.
And they typically use two hands because
they're not lined up well to throw.
If you watch a really good thrower,
like a grid iron football player,
a baseball player,
or a hunter gatherer throw,
you know it's a full body motion to step
forward with the other leg.
There's this rotation and the very last
minute you bring your risks through.
Well what that does is it creates an
enormous amount of elastic energy across
your muscles,
tendons and ligaments.
And the end of that throw for a human is
like the snapping of a rubber band.
So chimps can't do that.
They're not lined up properly.
But australopithecus got to the point
where they could probably do that pretty
well.
And so now,
and this purely a byproduct to
bipedalism because it's stretched out
their whole body and they don't,
they're not climbing as much anymore.
So their musculature is more lateral,
which would have been helped them for
throwing.
So now you get to a point where they
have access to the single most important
military intervention in history,
which is the capacity to kill it a
distance.
So if you and I are running around the
savannah and lion attacks us and we got
50 of our best friends,
we could kill it with our bare hands,
but a lot of us are going to die in the
process,
right?
Because you think 50 of us can get 100
that someone think even though it was
with a bunch of Nice and shy and I'd be
super confident where other people you
wouldn't worry very much but.
But even if we could.
So we knew what we're doing.
We're all armed with knives,
whoever,
whoever goes first screwed right.
And so the capacity to kill the distance
that will allows a larger force of
weaker individuals to come to easily
defeat a stronger individual.
And so once they gained this capacity to
throw,
if they were attacked by lions or
something like that,
whereas in the past they just scattered
for the trees.
Now they could throw stones at it and
defend themselves now.
And australopithecus throwing rocks at
alliant is going to be in the belly of a
slightly annoyed line in about three
minutes.
Right?
But 50 australopithecines throwing rocks
at Lyons is a totally different story
and so it's the.
This is the idea,
here is the throwing hypothesis there,
what,
what changed?
Everything was throwing and the reason
it changed everything is that it caused
us.
It was the first reason why we should
have any effective collective action
because it's not a good strategy when
you're on your own.
It's not a good strategy if I do it in
the rest of the group hits heads for the
trees,
but it's a great strategy if we all do
it together.
And so for the first time in history,
the group's goals in our history,
in our line,
the primate line,
the group's goals aligned with the
individual goals,
which is let's cooperate and work
together to try to drive away these
predators.
Now it,
if you look at a lion and you look at
someone throwing rocks,
it still seems like a really big ask,
right?
To drive that thing away or kill it,
throwing rocks.
And so.
But Barbara Isaac was one of the first
anthropologist to propose this
hypothesis quite awhile ago.
Went Back and looked through the
historical record and these
extraordinary stories of how effective
people are throwing rocks and so in,
when the Portuguese went to the Canary
Islands to try to subjugate it,
they rock up with,
you know,
armor guns,
uh,
crossbows and this isn't the 14
something
and all the locals were on with,
with stones and despite the fact that
the Portuguese are there in army
trained,
you know,
ready to shoot and,
and in their armor they were just
decimated by the local stone rock
center.
And the stories happened over and over
again.
And when you read these accounts,
they're extraordinary.
I can read you some examples from here.
They just,
the happened in Australia,
it happened in the Canary Islands that
happened elsewhere.
They just throw rocks incredibly
accurately,
incredibly hard and really fast.
So,
and there's know accounts in Africa
basically killing a zebra with one blow
of Iraq to the head.
So like a pitcher of major league
pitcher.
Exactly what rock who gets very accurate
at it.
Yeah.
So do you think they must have practiced
constantly.
And so what I suspect is that we evolved
to like to throw rocks and so if I let
you know,
if I look at my son as a,
for example,
when he was 18 months old,
we will be walking back toward that.
Sophie saw a rock on the street,
he pick it up and started trying to
throw it.
And my wife was like,
no,
don't let him throw rocks.
It's only going to cause trouble.
First of all I'm thinking,
well maybe I'll develop a good arm so
I'm going to go ahead and let him
anyway.
But secondly,
he fricking wants to.
This is something inherently fun for
him,
right?
And I think all humans enjoy throwing
and it's stunning how good you can get
it with practice.
So,
um,
we were at the Ohio state fair this
before my son was born and I was walking
by one of these stalls where you can
throw in a radar gun.
And so I thought the,
I was just starting to date my wife and
I thought,
oh,
here's a perfect chance to impress her.
Right?
And how,
how much you I am.
So I said,
hey,
why don't I stop and I'll throw some
balls here and this net,
because I hadn't ever thrown.
I didn't know how fast I could.
So she's like,
sure.
And I was,
I played like literally Greg.
So I throw the ball and it's like 50
miles an hour and she's pretty impressed
because that's sounds fast,
right?
Then it's like kid shows up next to me,
it's got to be 12 years old,
probably weighs 85 pounds.
This total gangland not a muscle in his
body.
And he just starts to fricking thrown
ball after ball at like 65 miles an
hour.
And I'm like fuck,
I mean she's not going to be impressed
because it's like human twig next to me
is kicking my ass.
Right?
And so I pick up the last ball,
I fucking throw it as hard as I can,
hurts my shoulder,
flies off at an odd angle,
doesn't hit anything,
and it's like 57 miles an hour.
Now,
that little guy who's like literally the
size of the nostril,
pythagoras was thrown at 65 and hitting
the target every time.
And so it's obvious that it's skill,
it's practice that would've made you
good at this,
and if your life depends on it,
you're going to do it.
Well.
That makes sense.
Coming from a martial arts background,
like coordinated movement where at the
end of it you snap exactly makes sense
that this technique is so critical,
even though you're a larger person.
So better technique would have more of
an impact with that.
So the throwing arm,
I had read this and if that was one of
the hypothesis,
several hypothesis,
why the human brain doubled over a
period of 2 million years.
Another one was cooked meat,
right?
They figured out a way to get more
nutrients out of meat that's writing
over fire,
right?
So that's a little bit down the road.
So here we are and a half million years
ago.
And so for the first time we put some
pressure on ourselves to have an
advantage to be smarter.
So imagine you're a zebra.
You know what the hell good is it to you
to be Einstein.
You got what are you going to do with
that brain?
Right?
But it's a big.
It's a big cost.
Our brains are 20 percent of our
metabolic energy,
whether we're doing math or watching tv,
it's,
it's constant drain.
And so what our ancestors,
why would they pay for that drain?
Now,
just recently,
there was a paper that came out maybe
three months ago now on um,
a new brand expansion gene.
They found it or they think that's what
it is called notch to an l.
and it turns out,
I don't know,
12,
15 million years ago,
there was an accidental duplication of
that gene on our genome and it,
but it was ineffective and it just sat
there doing nothing.
Now that's a great way that evolution
works where it accidentally doubles the
gene because then you don't,
you can mess with it.
And the old jeans still doing the job,
right?
So it sat there for about 9 million
years in our line till about 3 million
years ago,
round Australopithecus.
And then it duplicated itself and it
came online again.
And what that gene seems to do is it
makes our brain remain as stem cells for
longer,
which means a lot more duplication
before they run away.
And start becoming neurons.
And so if I had to guess,
I'd say that that probably that gene
coming online probably happened many
times in the past and every time it
happened in the past it was more costs
than it was worth.
And so what's the chimp going to do with
a little bit more brain and just needs
more calories and what does he gain from
it?
But now that we're working together,
now that we have collective action,
all sorts of things open up,
we could,
we could devise division of labor,
I'll say,
hey man,
you do this and I'll do that.
Because also the [inaudible],
they've got 70 more grams and a chimp.
They can't do things like that,
but they can all throw rocks at the same
time.
That's not rocket science,
but all the kinds of things that came
next probably were enabled by that
process of us coming together and
deciding to work together and cooperate.
So if you look at chimpanzees,
they don't cooperate very well.
Um,
for example,
one of the activities were they sort of
cooperate is when they hunt monkeys.
And so the law gather around and they'll
see some monkeys in the trees and they
come in from every angle.
It's not very coordinated.
It's kind of a wild free for all.
But what's interesting about it is that
when the hunts over,
let's say you just sat there the whole
time and watched and I'm working my ass
off chasing these monkeys,
I got one.
You come up and bug me for it and I
don't.
I don't willingly handle it.
You like keep nudging me until I share,
but I'm just as likely to share with you
if you helped as if you didn't.
I don't make any distinction.
And you'll never established effective
groups if you can't reward those who
participate compared to those who don't.
Even little kids,
four year old kids.
When you give them games to play and
they earn stickers.
If you didn't play,
you don't.
When you come up and ask,
you don't get it.
You played.
Even if you didn't do your job right,
but you tried,
boom,
you can have a sticker.
So humans immediately get that,
that you get rewarded for your
activities as part of the group.
Chimps don't seem to have that.
That's fascinating because.
But because chimps really do have a
sense of fairness though,
and that,
that's one of the issues that happened
with the captive chimps that attack the
man who brought the birthday cake.
Do you know that story?
I don't know.
That's too awful story.
These couple,
they kept a chimp as a pet for a long
time and then as it got older it got a
little violent and they had to bring it
to a sanctuary and they brought it to a
sanctuary and they would go to visit it
and the chimp would remember them and
they went to visit it and it was on his
birthday.
So they brought him a cake.
And the other chimps in the sanctuary
were furious that they didn't get the
cake,
uh,
as well.
They didn't think it was fair or they're
angry.
So they figured out somebody had left a
gate open and they got out and tour this
guy apart because he didn't give them a
cake.
Yeah.
So there's the most famous example of
that is actually with capital and
monkeys,
which aren't nearly as smart as chimps,
and it's this amazing study by Sarah
Bronfman and Frans de Waal,
and if you want to see it in action,
dwell has it on a Ted talk.
It's really quite something to see.
And what they do in that study is a
teacher these capuchin monkeys to.
They give them pebble and they teach the
captions to return the pebble and they
give it a cucumber slice.
And so it's learning the game for
cucumber slices.
So if you wanted to ask,
does the monkey think that's a fair
reward?
The answer has to be yes.
Right,
because it's.
It's doing that for cucumber.
So now you and I are.
Both monkeys were in our cage.
I returned the pebble,
I get a cucumber.
Now you return the pebble and they hand
you a great capuchins.
Much prefer grapes over cucumbers.
And so then what happens next?
Well,
I've been doing this behavior for
cucumbers,
but as soon as you get a great,
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm not playing anymore.
And you watch this tape and the cabbage
in it.
They give you a great,
they give me the cucumber and the thing
looks totally pissed.
It starts pounding on the ground and
throws the cucumber back or it's
amazing.
Yeah.
Well,
so the question is what does that mean?
Why do they care about fairness in that
way?
And,
and I think the answer to that question
is sexual selection.
And so the key to sexual selection is it
doesn't matter what everybody's getting
so long as I'm getting about as much as
everybody else,
but at the second that you're starting
to get more than I have.
Well then whatever females in our group,
she's going to pick you before she picks
me.
And so everything is relative.
We may think now,
why do you care so much about what other
people are doing?
Why don't you just be happy with what
you got?
But literally the day you find out that
the guy in the studio over salary's
twice years,
your salary sucks because it makes sense
because literally she's going to choose
him now before she chooses you
comparison's the thief of joy.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
It's a.
it's a really unfortunate fact because,
and sometimes it matters a lot.
Like for example,
imagine I invented drug and I say here,
take a dose in,
it'll double your Iq.
Instantly you're going to feel like a
genius,
but unbeknownst to I gave everybody two
doses.
You walk out of there,
you're going to feel like a dumb ass
because there's people saying stuff you
can understand,
right?
So then it would matter,
but the killer cases or things where
where it's only just a residence.
For example,
there's this amazing study where they
showed that people were making minimum,
just above minimum wage are the ones who
don't want you to raise minimum wage to
the most against it real.
Now,
why would that be?
Well,
right now they've got a slight advantage
over people making minimum wage.
The day minimum wage gets raised now
they're not any better off than anybody
else.
So even though they're the most likely
to from it,
because they
may lose that job,
they have enough to take minimum wage.
They're actually against it because it
gives them a slight advantage over,
you know,
the guy next door.
This is based on one study because I
would think that the people that would
be most against it will be the people
that are hiring folks are at.
Fair enough.
It's only,
it's only looking at income so the boss
probably feels even the more negative of
all,
but if you look at people's income and
their and their feelings about raising
the minimum wage that people are making
minimum wage wanted to go up the people
one notch above do not and then as the
higher you go,
they do again.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Up until you get to the point where
you're employing people and some
employers want to raise it.
Right?
I mean,
and some don't.
There's huge argument about that.
Now when it comes back to the capital
and monkeys does the same effect happen
whether it's a female or a male.
I don't know.
I mean so thing is people argue like
crazy about exactly what this means.
I don't think the monkeys have a sense
of fairness like you and I have,
but I do think they have a sense of,
hold on,
you're getting more than I am.
I can't let this happen,
otherwise I'm screwed and there's lots
of great evidence that if you let that
happen,
you're screwed.
But do the females have that same sense
of competitiveness that they need to
have the exact same thing,
those other bitches or having to get
angry?
Well,
here's the thing,
it depends on whether you're mating
system is going to be pair bonding or
not,
so if you're a frog or a lots of
different products,
not all of them are laughing tree frog
or if you're a elephant seal or
something,
we'll all the females mate with the best
male because his job is just sex and so
every female can add the best one or the
either in a situation where they've got
no choice like the elephant seals.
He controls the rookery or in a
situation where they just listened to
all the croaking and then the guard.
You're the best broker,
you're the dad,
but if your pair bonding like humans or
like lots of other animals,
birds,
etc.
The then what you need is you've got
competition on both sides.
So she's always compeTing to get the
best male and he's always competing to
get the best female.
And there's reasons why male male
competition is always a bit more intense
than female female competition.
But both of them are there.
And the more monogamous the system gets,
the more both sides compete for each
other.
Hm,
interesting.
So what about in the case of like
bonobo's where they're.
So polyamorous and elbows are super
interesting systems.
So you've got lots of polyamorous
animals,
um,
banabos or interests.
Their chimps are also,
you know,
so if you look at,
um,
one of the great ways to look at our
ancestors and what their lives were like
because you look in your trousers and
the size of your testicles tells you a
lot about what sort of mating system
your ancestors had.
So gorillas have tiny little testicles
and the reason that they have such tiny
testicles as they use their huge body to
drive away the other males and then all
the females are in his harem so he
doesn't need big testicles because he
only needs a sperm in order to
inseminate the females he's got.
it doesn't take much sperm to inseminate
anyone.
Female and testicles are really
expensive tissue to make.
And if you want a pair and you land on
them,
you know they're uncomfortable too.
Right?
And so then you look at our testicles
and they're quite a bit bigger than a
gorillas,
but they're nowhere near the size of a
chimp or urbanova.
Both.
They're baSically in many ways almost
the same beast and so although socially
quite different and they have a system
where they basically have to wash out
the guy who was there before them.
And so it takes really big testicles to
have sperm competition.
So their competition is.
And by fighting each other,
although there's a degree of that too,
they know full well that when she comes
into estrus,
into heat,
there's going to be aligned.
And if you're fifth in line and you can
wash everybody out before you might end
up the dad wash everybody out.
It was a funny way of putting it.
So it's not.
It's a this,
this testicle size is directly
proportionate to the number of
promiscuous females.
Well,
that's right.
The promise acuity the mating system.
And so if you look at our mating system,
we clearly evolved to be largely
monogamous,
but not entirely.
Our testicles are unnecessarily large
for for an entirely monogamous species.
And so we're a little bit on the wash
the guy out ahead of us.
There's many people to make arguments
that are monogamy's socially reinforced
and it's not natural.
Look,
if you look at hunter gatherers and and
so the best,
the best way that we get a sense of,
well what did we evolve to do is to look
at the remaining hunter gatherer
societies,
particularly if you look at what are
called immediate return on togethers.
So there are people who eat today,
what they killed today.
You've got a lot of hunter gatherers.
Once they left the equator,
they could store food and everything
changed for them.
And they actually,
in many of the behaviors,
they look a lot like us and we can come
back to that if you'd like,
but if you look at hunter gathers around
the equator there typically immediate
return,
kill,
eat,
and so those guys tend to be,
tend to be,
there's always,
of course human differences where it's
super variable species,
but they tend to be serially monogamous.
And so some people pair up for life,
lots of people pair up for five,
seven years and then break apart and
pair up again.
And so you have a sequence of children
with the secrets of people,
but,
but largely monogamists not entirely.
And in fact,
monogamous during those time periods,
largely now we know every single animal
we've ever described as monogamous.
When we do the dnA,
we now find they're not entirely,
but they're mostly.
Hm.
Interesting.
So,
um,
have you ever had sex at dawn?
What did you think of that?
Um,
no offense,
but I think it's total crap.
Oh,
chris ryan,
do you hear that shit?
Everybody's rocking on your book,
bro.
Uh,
what,
what did you think is crap about it?
I just don't think the system works that
way.
The the explain to people that may or
may not know what we're talking about.
I haven't read that book now since it
came out,
so let me remind,
remind me the thesis.
Do you remember it off?
The idea is that we evolved in these
small tribes of people that essentially
shared sexual partners.
That's bullshit.
And so the thing is that what makes you
say that so confidently?
well,
I don't know.
I shouldn't say quite so confidently.
You're absolutely right.
I believe that's bullshit.
How's that?
Okay.
Why do you believe that's bullshit?
Because I'm so human beings have very
clear evolve jealousy systems and
they're not just a product of the world
that we live in today.
You can see jealousy among hunter
gatherers as well.
Now the thing is they get jealous
about different things because of course
men and women are slightly different
pressure on them,
but they both get jealous by infidelity.
Now that's not to say that the book is
incorrect about some societies in some
places because one of the interesting
things about humans is our flexibility
and so you can create a system and some
hunter gatherers have where there's a
lot of that,
a ton of that to some really interesting
ones were literally once the woman gets
pregnant,
she then starts to sleep with all the
other males because she thinks her baby
will gain the qualities of all the men
that she sleeps with.
So I'm not trying to claim that we're
always monogamous Because absolutely
that's untrue.
but I do think that the dominant system
is one of serial monogamy.
And the reason I think that that's the
dominant system is this is kind of the
deal that we made whereby the males go
out and do the hunting.
The females go out and do gathering.
And that's basically universal.
She tends to cook for him And that comes
back to the fire point you made,
which we can come back to.
And um,
and so they share resources and,
and he's happy to share resources and do
his best to kinda sorta look out for her
kids.
I mean human males aren't,
we don't take as much care as human
females do have our kids,
but we're much better than the other
great apes.
And so that level of investment he's
going to make his,
tends to be to the degree that he
believes that he's the father of the
kids.
Now you have societies where he doesn't
know that really all are polyamorous
like that by all means.
I don't know what percentage they are
and it could even be,
they're more common than I believe,
but when that happens,
the systems tend to change a little bit
and he's a little bit less willing to
look out,
try to help out kids other than to do
her a favor unless the kid looks a lot
like himself.
Now what about why having a system,
a biological system where jealousy comes
up?
What makes you think that that somehow
or another negates the idea of
polyamorous relationships?
Well,
it does suggest that they're not our
default because it doesn't more likely
suggests that it encourages competition,
which is just natural
when we think about envy instead of
jealousy,
and so if I'm jealous,
I'm upset that my wife slept with
somebody else last night.
He could be a low life.
I don't envy a thing about him.
I don't want anything he owns,
but I'm jealous of her behavior.
I'm.
I'm protective of what she's done and so
there's a wonderful experiment.
David buss has run at the university of
Texas stuff.
They're jealous of the man as well.
You're not just jealous of her behavior.
You're jealous of this other male that
gets to have sex with your wife and
could not possibly encourage competition
and encourage men to be more aggressive
or more ingenious or just create
encouraged creativity and courage,
better hunting skills.
So you attract more women.
I mean,
all those things seem to control.
YeaH,
I would agree with all that.
I phrased it a little bit differently.
So there's this wonderful study out of
the Philippines where they measured
men's huge number of men's testosterone
when they were single and then they
waited a few years and measured it again
after they were.
They were still single or now they're
married and now they're married and they
have kids and I'm sure it wasn't a
psychology study because we can't afford
to do that.
It was probably some medical thing,
but they used to to answer this
interesting psychological question,
which what's have,
who's most likely to get the girl by the
original testosterone levels and what
happens when you do?
Well,
the guys who got married in the
intervening few years had higher
testosterone than the guys who didn't.
So yeah,
you're absolutely right.
we're out there competing with other
males in order to get the girl and
there's lots and lots of goes on there.
Tons of really interesting things.
but what's interesting is once we get
the girl are testosterone drops and so
if we.
Once we partner up and if we're in a
monogamous relationship,
not polyamorous,
but in a monogamous relationship,
our testosterone drops and then it drops
again.
If we have kids and testosterone is a
great hormone for getting out there and
being competitive with other guys,
it's not a great hormone for being
nurturing for your children and it's not
a great hormone for being faithful to
your partner and so I think that we
evolved to compete with other males in
order to get into the mating game.
So if you look at our ancestral dna,
you know how you can track our male and
female ancestry through mitochondrial
dna in the mother's side and why you'll
see that we have far more female
ancestors than male,
not quite two to one,
But I think it's close to that.
And so what does that tell us?
Well,
lots of guys are getting left out of the
mating game entirely and lots of guys
are inseminating,
lots of different women.
So all those things that you said are
absolutely true and all that pushes us
for competition,
but part of what I believe goes on as
part of that competition that we engaged
in was in order to get the girl to get
into that relationship in the first
place.
Could I stop you there?
Because I think that if you're going to
have a study on testosterone and you
have to have a study on lifestyle,
I mean you,
if you get married and you have
children,
one of the things that happens is you
become less active.
You'd be,
you don't exercise as much,
you don't sleep as much.
All those things have a pretty radical
effect on hormone production.
Absolutely.
And it could well be that,
you know,
you always have to have a proximal
mechanism whereby evolution plays its
game,
right?
So the distal cause is as,
as an evolved species where testosterone
is super important to get us into the
mating game,
but it's less useful once we're in it.
Well all you could,
you could,
all you have to do is have a system
whereby those things tend to
downregulate testosterone.
Exactly like you said,
because you know those things are gonna
happen once you get partnered up and so.
But mind you,
when our ancestors partnered up,
they're still out hunting every day.
You know,
we may be right.
You don't have Studies on.
Unfortunately we don't.
The issue is that I'm having with this
is we have studies on the general health
and testosterone and hormonal health of
sedentary humans.
Yeah,
I mean I would like to know what their
lifestyle is.
I would like to know what they're doing.
I'm sure that seem to make any sense to
me because one thing that everybody
knows is that you get dad bod,
right?
That's dad by what his dad bought.
Dad.
Bob's a guy who works all day,
comes home,
sits on the couch,
probably eats food.
You probably shouldn't eat,
hangs out with his kids,
doesn't get a whole lot of exercise,
works,
probably doesn't sleep as much as he
should.
That.
That's to me,
that's a symptom of poor health and
fitness.
Right?
And it's not a symptom or ancestors ever
experienced.
Not.
This is not necessarily an indication of
any sort of evolutionary benefit of
having low testosterone because we've
demonstrated for sure that when people
don't get sleep and when they don't get
exercise,
their testosterone drops.
So those are two things that absolutely
happen when you get married and have
children.
Right.
And the only thing I would say is the
times of the time span of this study was
only over a few years and let's see.
The worst thing about having this kind
of a study and making these kinds of
kind of conclusions based on.
I mean we see,
we know these mechanisms are in place,
we already know that there's natural
effects of sedentary lifestyle,
lack of sleep,
and the effects are your hormone
production drops,
your body suffers,
you become less healthy.
And this is.
This is not indicating monogamy,
this is just indicating poor health.
This is not like an evolutionary
advantage to having low testosterone
because it helps you raise children.
You can have high testosterone is still
be a good dad and raise children and
still have friends.
That theme,
of course,
all of these things are bell curves,
right?
The higher you are,
the harder it gets.
Part of the problem I'm having iS,
is drawing conclusions on this one study
and stating them as if they're facts.
No,
you're absolutely right.
I,
if I say it's a fact,
it's certainly overstated because we
only know the problem with almost all of
our studies is the exact one you pointed
out.
We've got them on us.
We don't have.
So like the sex studies are a perfect
example.
Like things like female orgasm.
What role does it play?
Well,
you need really good data on hunter
gatherers to know the answer to that
question.
If you look at hunter gatherers,
they don't have dad bod,
right?
They're all running and whether their
fathers are not because they're out
there hunting every day or gathering
everyday.
Very physically active.
So if I,
if I oversold that,
my apologies.
Because you're absolutely right.
I suspect though that you'd find the
same thing.
I don't know it.
It's all we got right now,
but how can you suspect it?
I mean it just,
there's no data,
there's no data.
It just,
when you look
these guys,
I have a friend of mine who he was,
was it,
how'd you say the name?
The yanomami in Bolivia.
Bolivia.
Whether in Venezuela,
Brazil.
Yeah.
And he spent some time with them and you
see these people and the lifestyle they
live,
they're all barefoot wandering through
the jungle.
They have these crazy looking feet,
whether their toes splay out because
they're just constantly gripping the
floor with their toes when they probably
could choke you with me,
you know,
and these people just look so fit and
healthy in their,
in their fifties and sixties and
seventies.
And they have their shirt off and
they're ripped.
Yeah,
they're super fit.
Same holds.
If you look at the hubs in Tanzania,
any of these groups,
the yanomamo are interesting because
they're a hunter horticulturalist,
so they're actually doing a little bit
of gardening as well.
But they're ripped and strong and they
don't have obesity problem.
And so all I would say is That the same
thing holds.
The one thing that we found in humans in
our modern culture where we have these
data is if you're married and have kids,
but you're still looking,
your tea hasn't gone down as much that
you're going to point out quite rightly
that well maybe that's a different kind
of person than the person who marries
and isn't looking around,
and so it's all confounded,
super hard to do experiments on these
things and we'll be a lot better off
when we've got,
as you know,
we're losing the world's last hunter.
Gatherers are disappearing and it's not
easy to collect these kinds of data,
but they're doing lots of genetic work
with these people right now all over
africa because you know,
there's.
We've got tons of genetic data now on
european descent and east asian descent,
but almost none on africans and so
that's a huge project underway and so
for all I know,
they're working on hormones and other
things as well.
Yeah.
That's the reason why I'm asking about
this is you.
You were so readily dismissing.
You were so willing to dismiss that,
but yeah.
Well,
the.
A lot of the facts that are laid out as
facts in the book don't really hold up
and I'm in.
I wish I'd read it more recently and so
I could go through the details with you.
There's some really good reviews by
anthropologists and by people who work
in,
you know,
sexual studies and stuff like that.
Going through the details.
We read it as a,
we haven't this evolutionary center
center for psychology and evolution and
we read it and went through it and we
weren't convinced.
I'm embarrassed to admit I can't
remember the details of.
Chris is a very smart guy and he's a
good friend of mine.
also a great book.
It is a great book.
I would love to see him debate one of
those folks.
I'm sure he probably has.
He probably has.
And look,
I know that all these things that we're
talking about are heavily debated,
right?
So.
So my colleague rob brooks is a
wonderful evolutionary biologists and
Australia loves that book.
So the fact that I think it's bullshit
is obviously one person's opinion.
Where I.
I dismissed that argument.
Other people might say,
well look,
there's a lot of cultures that they do
have much more like the system I told
you about where they have sex with lots
of men after they have their baby.
Humans are so flexible,
we can do all those things.
we just changed the nature of how we do
things.
The social leap that I'm arguing about
is not this pair bonding thing.
It's about how our groups came together
to engage in collective action.
so in principle,
I'm agnostic on this issue.
I just happen to disagree with that.
I happen to feel like no,
I think we made these deals.
And so to come back to the study,
the david buss did that I started to
tell you about.
So bas has this,
um,
he's got,
when he came along,
people thought that the two sexes had
similar levels of jealousy for
infidelity.
And david was like,
well,
looks inseminations internal.
And so men should be a lot more worried
about her sleeping with somebody else
than women should be because he.
Men never know for sure if they're the
father,
they can't see it happen.
Whereas,
you know,
if you're a salmon,
you can say,
okay,
I'm the debt,
I just watched that,
but um,
females inseminations turn,
but they know they're the mother.
That's not their concern.
They should be more concerned about
things like his given her resources to
help her raise the kids and things like
that.
And so what bus found is if you ask
people this question,
what would bother you more?
Imagine your wife having sex with
somebody that she just met for the first
time,
having this great time and doing all
these different things with them and
then never doing it again.
Or your wife develops this,
you know,
ongoing,
emotional connection with somebody.
She never touched him.
He never touches her,
but they talk and have shared their
feelings and stared deep in each other's
eyes.
What would bother you more?
And you ask men and women that question.
So what would,
in your case,
what would bother you to have your wife
to know?
She had this one off a fair fling.
Sex only didn't care about the guy or
she develops a sort of emotional bond
with somebody.
Never touches it.
That's a good question.
I'd really have to think about that.
It's not an easy one because nobody
likes either of them.
No.
Yeah,
because it's a matter of time for that
dude gets in.
That's a no.
The guarantee in this case is the
guarantee.
It's a guarantee that they never,
never touched.
Never.
As long as he doesn't talk shit about
me.
That's the problem.
Those guys,
they started the pool.
I would do so much better.
Right?
Well,
here's the thing.
Weasels,
on average,
men are more bothered by sex.
The one off sex and women are more
bothered by the emotional,
emotional connection because connection
could lead to him leaving her.
Well also,
if it's him leaving her directing his
resources elsewhere,
so it's,
it's mind you,
every time we talk about gender
differences is super important to keep
in mind.
They're heavily overlapping bell curves,
so it's never 100 percent this way and
except like do you have this Oregon or
something?
But psychologically it's always
overlapping,
but on this is a big effect.
Men on average are much more bothered by
the one off sex and women on average are
much more
bothered by the emotional connection.
Yeah,
that's fascinating because I was reading
something about inappropriate emotional
relationships that people have at work
and that this is an issue with people
that work together.
They develop these office friendships
that lead to inappropriate emotional
relationships and I was like,
whoa,
this is a,
you know,
I've never worked in an office so I'm
listening to this or reading this
rather.
And I'm like,
what a strange world that is.
Like,
I get it though.
I get it.
Like if there's a guy and he's married
and a gal and she's married,
but they meet at work and they stare in
each other's eyes all day and they go to
lunch and maybe they even hold hands
every now and then.
Well,
they become.
That's where it crosses the line.
Like you're allowed to hug people when
you hold hands.
That's fucking.
That's tense.
That skin to skin.
It is serious.
It's going to concern you if you're a
partner,
but what's also going to concern you as
a mere fact that you see this kind of
thing,
this deep conversation happening and all
that,
because think about it.
If we evolve to basically partner up for
awhile,
then there's always going to be the
chance that that next person long it's
gonna be the one which is years away
serial monogamy and both males and
females gain from not putting all their
eggs into the same genetic basket.
So if my.
If my wife partners up with you for
awhile,
she'll get a certain kind of offspring
and then maybe that'll be a great thing,
but maybe when the situation changes or
the in tomorrow's world,
some smaller guy would be handy
in some way and so maybe she's better
off partnering with me next.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It is fascinating when you break it down
that it really does become.
There's a biological reason for these
behaviors and these are the motivation
for the jealousy and all these things
that there's.
There's a history of biological history
to all this
stuff and we don't know what hunter
gathers how they would answer that
question so we can only just assuming
that the answer we're providing is
general,
but for me,
those kinds of things suggests that we
evolved.
We evolved in a lot of longterm
monogamous circumstances that may have
been serial and there was certainly
fooling around,
but if we were polyamorous,
like the book says we'd have bigger
balls.
Are balls are so big though,
compared to a chimp there.
Small.
Yeah.
But chimps are.
I mean,
everything's big with them.
Well,
no.
Our penis is way bigger than theirs.
They got a tiny little.
They have large.
Paul's smaller penises.
Puppets would probably get in the way.
Right.
When though.
Here's the thing about,
so human beings copulate for an
extraordinarily long period of time and
we also have this cryptic ovulation,
you know,
where she's not showing you that she's
in heat,
so mail chimp's aren't interested unless
she has an enormous swelling on her
vagina and then they're like,
oh,
that's super attractive to me.
Oh,
I say,
but what about banabos?
Because they,
well,
they do this funky sex thing all the
time.
Right?
Have fun,
right?
Yeah.
They're all sorts of funky orgiastic
kinds of things.
We used,
there's a,
when I taught at Ohio state university
that the zoo there has a great exhibit
and you bring your kids through and
there's a series orgy going on and the
kids are like,
came out and she said,
yeah,
there's a lot of zoos that won't happen.
Novos,
because they're pretty interesting.
And so the thing is that those kinds of
things just show you that it's
complicated,
right?
Any kind of straightforward answer that
it's going to have some wrinkles.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I apologize if I get some earlier.
No worries.
And so anyway,
the um,
the but back to this issue.
So if we had a total bonobo,
chimp kind of system,
I don't think we had evolved those
systems of jealousy because what's,
what's to be gained by that we're not
making these longterm partners.
Why would you get these differences?
again,
whenever I bring chris's book up,
I have to defend it because it has
happened a couple times in the last
year.
I haven't read it and at least two years
I'd have to go back and I read it back
over five years ago,
but someone who came out,
when my friend's wife got ahold of it,
my friend got it and my friend's wife
got all of it
to a right in the trash.
She read like a paragraph or two and she
was like,
fuck this book.
A lot of women react that way and I
can't remember why.
Yeah,
sorry,
I just don't have it loaded up.
Whatever.
Um,
so when these chimp,
like creatures from millions of years
ago,
slowly started walking upright and
started moving into the grasslands and
making,
making experiments and traveling away
from the jungle.
And this coincided the development of
the throwing arm and this could because
they started walking upright.
When did this,
when did the cooked meat
come along?
So they don't control fire.
so also can't do that.
So now we go forward.
We're now about three and a half million
yearS ago.
You got to now go forward to about a
little less than 2 million years ago to
get to homo erectus.
So once we get to homo erectus,
we now got an,
uh,
an ancestor that literally,
if it went to the z,
you'd say,
well that's a kind of rough hewn guy,
but you think it's a person and not
somebody who bought belongs behind the
glass.
So,
so a chimp brain is three 80
australopithecus for 50 and homoerectus
nine slash 60.
Whoa.
So you got doubling.
A brain says,
no,
mind you.
It's a bigger being.
So it's not as quite as big dramatic of
a change as you think.
But along with that comes all sorts of
capabilities.
Now you write about this book catching
fire.
Richard wrangham argued that what
enabled that?
So if you look at the gut of a gorilla
or a chimpanzee in their brain,
they got a lot of guts for a little bit
of brain because it takes a lot of
digestion to keep a little bit of brain
going.
We have a tiny gut for a huge brain and
rang a argues,
and I think quite rightly,
that the only way you can achieve that
is by releasing more nutrients from your
food.
And the only way you can release more
nutrients from your food is by cooking
it.
So when he made that argument,
he thinks it goes back to the beginning
of homo erectus.
And I suspect he's right at this point.
When he made the argument,
we.
It was only back to,
I don't remember half a million years,
350,000.
It's already back to a million years
ago.
We found in caves in South Africa,
evidence of control of fire.
and so it'll probably keep getting
pushed back because you know that crap.
It's hard to find.
So this was a half million years,
so now it's back to a million
millionaires.
And he made that prediction when it
wasn't even that far back
in a million years ago,
even though they're not technically not
homeless.
No,
we're still at home erectus.
And so they started a one point nine or
so,
one point 7 million years ago.
And one point nine,
I think.
And what homo erectus could now do.
So now remember what the argument is,
this social leap,
it's this collective action that not
only protects us on the savanna but sets
us on this new pathway.
It creates this new niche.
It's this cognitive niche,
although I think of it as a social
cognitive niche because it's the working
together that gives you all these
potential advantages to getting smarter
and so now when that gene sitting in our
head,
if it kicks into gear those and starts
to work and it leads to cranial
expansion,
those animals will have and will have an
advantage because they can coordinate
with each other better and so they can
remember,
hey man,
you helped me out last time but you
weren't.
So yeah,
couldn't count on you.
So I'm avoiding you and I'm sticking
with you.
They can do a lot of things with that
brainpower and by the time you get to
homo erectus and the brain power is
doubled.
We see all sorts of super interesting
things.
So before homo erectus,
when you look at our tools,
it's called an older one tool and it's
basically a barely sharpened rock and
you never find an older one tool to very
far away from wherever it was quarried
and made like,
you know,
you look at the rock and the chips and
not far away is where it's lying on the
ground.
Homo erectus made a much nicer tool.
It's bi-facial.
It took a lot of energy to make it.
When we teach modern anthropologists or
grad students or whatever to make them
and you put them in an mri magnet where
it can measure your metabolism and your
brain is you go,
you see that it takes a lot of frontal
lobe functioning in order to make one
because it's a lot of planning.
how am I going to hit it next to make
this thing just right compared to an
older one tool to make those doesn't
take much frontal functioning.
Just racket there and it'll be sharp.
And so the first of all,
we know homo erectus invented that tool,
this,
this assurion tool with his bi-facial
handhelds.
and second of all,
and one of my,
one of the coolest findings,
there's some interesting work in a one
point 2 million year old site in India,
uh,
by carrie sHipped and where he finds
that the production of these tools is
separated spatially about the place.
So the first step is bashing loose a big
piece of rock and that's done here.
And then 10 meters over there,
somebody doing the initial chipping on
it and 10 meters over there,
somebody sharpening up the final
touches.
Now,
if you were making it by yourself,
why would you systematically walk around
the site as you made it?
You almost assuredly wouldn't.
But if you've got division of labor,
you're the big strong guy,
you do the first thing,
then you hand it to me and I do the
finer sharpening.
It makes sense that it would be
spatially distributed about the site.
So there's that evidence for division of
labor.
There's the evidence that they're
bringing down some pretty fast animals
like horses and potentially even
bringing down elephants,
which in those days are like twice the
size of an elephant and then they using
spirits at that point we don't know
because they didn't survive.
Right.
And nothing would is still around.
There's no sign of hafting anything.
So if it was beers it would have been a
wooden point.
so I think what they could meaning the
end of it like cut in half.
so you could stick an ear tip.
exactly.
And then exactly strapping it on or any
of a variety of were put.
Yeah.
And so they.
There was no sign of that yet,
but there's no reason why they couldn't
have a sharpened spirit.
In fact,
we know that.
Remember the,
I mentioned the chimps in Senegal that
live on the savannah.
They're the only chimps on earth who do
this.
They'll bite the stick to sharpen it and
poke them monkeys to when they're in the
hollow of a tree and stab up.
Did you see that recent discovery and
I'm in.
It's really recently.
There was an article I read one or two
days ago at about orangutans when they
gave them wire.
They use the wire to fashion and into
fishhooks.
Now I didn't.
That's totally cool.
They figured out how to make a fishhook
independently and that's amazing.
You've seen them like spearfish,
right?
Hangover,
tornadoes that.
That's that.
That picture is actually of an orangutan
who's watched fishermen do this.
He couldn't do It.
Remember an orangutan,
if it meant you could literally pull
your arms off like that.
The enormous strength,
particular gearing for that strength.
They got very poor motor control like
you and I can type.
They can't do that.
Right.
And so that,
that orangutan,
that famous photo never could catch
anything,
seen it done and it was trying to see if
he could do it too.
Fair enough.
He's trying to use a timer but.
But you know,
there's these corporate,
these crows and such dell fashioned
hooks to.
Yeah.
So there's some,
there's a lot of amazing evidence for
this sort of animal ingenuity and making
tools will.
You've seen the studies with crows were
they use one stick to get a larger study
to get a larger food?
Amazing.
Now the one thing is we don't.
They can do that and then they fail some
super simple tests so it could be that
their brains tiny though they are
dedicated to a particular way of solving
a particular problem because it's
especially these ones that live in new
caledonia do this in the wild and so
they they fashioned amount of palm
fronds,
they tear it off and they reshape it and
then they hook insects out of the bark
of trees and stuff.
And so you could imagine that they've
kind oF learned a specific way of
problem solving,
but they can't do something that to you
because you would solve that using some
pretty domain general mechanisms to you
looks the same.
But to them it's totally different.
Did you find a thing with the ringtones?
It's really crazy.
It's just a.
Well,
you know,
I'd read something.
Here we go rank 10 spontaneously.
Ben straight wires into hooks to fish
for food,
which is amazing.
Is they have a photo of a jamie if you
scroll down a little bit there,
but does that photo.
It's just.
I'll just him with a stick.
yeah,
that's really,
really cool.
I had read something a few years back
that said that they were agreeing that
chimpanzees had officially moved into
the stone age.
Yeah,
so chimpanzees were used stones as
tools,
so they'll crack nuts with them,
but they've never.
They've never been shown to modify stone
tiles and so if you want to say the
stone age,
doosan stones,
by all means,
if you want to say it's modifying
stones.
The the oldest evidence that we have
potentially modified is three point 3
million years ago.
These lamech we tools,
but there's argument about how legit
those right.
There's argument about a lot of those
sites too where they believe that they
find stone tools that are ancient
because it could easily just spend
shale.
Yeah.
And overwatch.
It's super complicated to know exactly
when it got laid down,
everyone.
So I'll get lucky and the and the layers
are super orderly and then when you get
to that layer,
you know exactly what you got,
but now what's the chances of finding
what you're after there?
Right now when they say the stone age,
that's what they mean.
Just the idea of consciously using a
rock to like smash open a clam or
something like that.
Yeah,
I mean,
to me that does.
I,
I gotta I gotta admit I'm not quite sure
technically what an anthropologist would
mean when they say stone age,
but um,
to what,
what we know is that chimps will do
that.
They'll use rocks to,
they'll even,
if they're clever enough to have an
anvil basically like her hammer ball
based on put a rock on it,
smash what?
They're not clever enough to do.
So chimps have partial theory of mind
and theory of mind is this idea that I
know that the contents of your mind
differ from the contents of mine.
And all humans get there when they're
little around age four.
And so the.
And you can see the penny drop because
they just assume everybody knows the
same things and everybody's the same
preferences and,
and that's why when they're really
little,
their stories can be hard to follow
because they assume what's in your head
is the same as theirs.
They assume you liked the same things.
And actually it turns out that the ones
who have siblings learn it earlier
because like,
oh you like the red jellybeans.
I like the green ones.
Awesome.
This is a beneficial deal for both of
us,
right?
Right.
Anyway,
can get partial theory of mind so I
could see what you could say.
I know what you could see at your angle
of how much chimp and I know that might
differ from what I could see,
but they can't get to the point of
knowing that you could represent beliefs
that aren't true,
that you could have deeply,
etc.
Or that maybe I don't like bananas,
but he does like,
but then they can't really get there.
And so what the problem is without
theory of mind,
how do you teach somebody?
Because if I just assume you know what I
know,
then when you're doing a crappy job
breaking the net,
I'm like,
what's wrong with joe here?
And so chip mothers take years to to
teach their offspring,
to break these nuts open 10 years on
average,
because first of all,
they don't get a chance to do it very
often.
Then that's got to be in season.
Second of all,
it's easy to bReak your fingers and that
kind of slows you down.
But third of all,
they'll occasionally make some very
specific corrections when the,
when the offspring is doing it wrong,
but they don't know what the problem is
because they don't know what the kid
doesn't know.
And so when you don't know that you
can't teach.
And that's why humans are stunningly
effective teachers.
That's fascinating.
So chimps learn more just by observing.
Yeah,
and what's amazing about the way chimps
observed is that because we have theory
of mind,
we also do imitate differently.
So there's this amazing experiment by
andy white and his colleagues and what
they did is they created this treasure
box.
And so inside this treasure box,
there is something that a chimp or a kid
wants,
like a little piece of food and in one
condition the box is totally opaque so
you can't see how it works and they'll
poke at the top of it and then the poke
in the middle and it pops open and then
they give it to the chimp,
close it up.
Chimp does the exact same thing.
Poke,
poke,
pops open,
give it to a kid,
does the exact same thing.
Now they do the,
they do the replicate that same
experiment,
but instead of having that box be
opaque,
it's translucent and you can see well
and truly the poking the top does
nothing.
The latch is actually right here and so
that initial poke was a waste of your
time.
This second one actually is one that
opened the box up when when chimps watch
that,
they skip the first one and they just
opened the box.
Kids despite being smarter than a chimp
poke at the top first and then they poke
it in the bottom and we call this over
imitation.
They're imitating clearly irrelevant
actions.
Now,
why would anybody imitate clearly
irrelevant actions?
WhAt advantage would it give you?
Well,
if you have theory of mind,
you say,
well that's joe's box.
He knows something about it.
There may be a reason why I can't see,
but then maybe reason why he's poking at
the top first,
and so I better do everything that he
does.
I better have the highest fidelity
copying that I possibly can because it
may be valuable.
And what you end up with is these
systems around the world where people
eat these amazing foods that you think
you know,
how on earth could they ever figured
that out?
Well,
it was probably developed step by step
and everybody's always got this super
high fidelity imitation because they're
over imitating.
So my favorite examples in new Guinea,
they,
the sago palm,
I'm not sure if you've ever seen a sago
palm,
but it does not look like an edible
tree.
It just looks like a free country.
Right?
And it turns out that if you,
you chop the tree down,
take the bark off,
take like an ads or something similar,
grind up the sawdust,
have all that sawdust.
you then wash it off in warm water
because of course all the water in new
Guinea will be nice and warm,
and that causes.
It's a super high starch tree that
causes the starch molecules to separate
from the sawdust because at that point
it's inevitable.
So then they have these cloth and the
starch molecules pass through the cloth,
the sawdust one.
Now they collect this cloudy water.
They put in these traditional canoes,
they let it sit overnight and all of the
starts sinks to the bottom.
Then they pour the water off the top and
now they've got this flower.
But you have to dry it out in the sun
really faster.
It becomes toxic.
So it's like this nine step process that
who on earth could ever come up with it,
right?
But once it's in place,
once they slowly figured it out to make
it work,
everybody just does it the same way
because even though they don't know,
they may understand it,
but they don't need to.
They just know this is how we do.
Well,
that's like that.
What is that root that they cassava?
Yeah.
That if you don't cook it correctly,
it's literally cyanide and they have
water from and they have to take that
water and they have the buckets of these
water,
the water for that they're using to
create this stuff and they just leave it
laying around and kids are playing
around it and the pigs and animals
around it.
And if they drank it,
they'd be dead.
Yeah.
I don't know.
The detoxing of cassava.
Unfortunate I'm not.
I'm not familiar with that.
But there's a lot of those examples and
you're also right that in those kinds of
societies,
they're super relaxed about things that
we strike the strike.
Kill you quote.
Exactly.
But that's tough.
it.
It becomes cyanide,
right?
You could be right.
I don't know that one.
See if you could find this because it's
on an episode of that same show.
It's this show is called meat eater.
It's my friend steve who went and spent
some time with them down in the jungle
south America.
It's really interesting stuff.
Just seeing how these people function
and and they have this big vat and
they're cooking this stuff and he was
explaining like right now if you hate
it,
you're dead.
You got to wait a while and like,
how the fuck did they figure this out?
Researchers to get to the sinai.
Oh,
cyanide producing abilities because I
was the third most important food source
in tropical countries,
but as one major problem,
the roots and the leaves of poorly
processed cassava plants contain a
substance that when eaten can trigger
the production of cyanide,
kills the shit out of you.
But it's weird that that thing is like a
major staple in their diet.
Well,
this is a really good example of a,
the value of human learning and this
over invitation process,
right?
Because the first guy where they go,
okay,
I'm not going to do that.
Right?
And then this person aided unaided
successful.
Let's take a look at what they did.
So I remember when I was a kid,
I was turned to learn to play baseball
and pitch the ball and the person raises
their knee almost up to their nipples.
And I'm like,
that's the most awkward pitching motion
I've ever seen.
But I didn't occur to me.
I'm not going to do that.
Right?
It occurred me.
Well,
there must be a reason to do that.
So,
um,
what can I do to try to emulate that
motion?
Right?
Right.
The whole,
the whole nine yards.
There's a purpose for every one of those
pieces.
And as humans we're saying,
well,
you're teaching me how you've got to
have a reason for doing that.
And that's the huge between us and
everybody
else.
Nobody else can do that theory of mind
thing to make that assumption.
And that's why the chimps skip that step
that they,
that they know at least in that
particular tournament is really actually
useless and kids don't.
So
you're a concept is that as these
animals that used to be monkeys start
evolving and trying out new things,
one thing that they learn as they enter
into this new climate as if there's a
massive benefit to.
Yes.
Now I would say it's not monkeys because
technically speaking aren't all apes
monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes?
No.
So a monkeys and apes are different.
They split off a month.
He's not a real word.
I mean it's not a word in terms of
scientific designation,
right?
Even the monkey of two different things.
Right?
But there's.
There's old world monkeys in new world
monkeys,
but all of them have a genus and species
that.
But it's not a scientific name,
right?
There's a key's not now they're
primates.
They're all privates.
What did I read?
The cv?
Google that google.
There was a whole
bullet.
Anthropologist wrote that.
Not all apes or monkeys,
but all monkey.
No,
not all monkeys or apes,
but all apes or monkeys because monkeys
almost a slang term
because it's bullshit.
I think it's bullshit,
but we'll find out that what I would say
is it all apes and monkeys are primates
and they all started from monkey
ancestry.
Right,
right.
And so.
But then the ape split off.
You've got to rang content.
The great apes are orangutans,
gorillas,
chimps and us,
and then you got gibbons which are
lesser apes,
which split off quite a while ago and
they're very different.
They don't have the brain power of the
great apes.
Do you find anything like that?
I read this a few years ago.
Was it confused the shit out of me
because I didn't know that monkey wasn't
a scientific term.
Well,
scientists talk about old world monkeys
in new world,
but it's almost a slang term as well.
Whenever you're.
If you're.
If you're a prepper biologist and you
have the species and say that was a
chimpanzee is thing I found.
Is it like pen light source,
but it pops up
on google.
Okay.
Comes up,
but it's a longer.
It's there's more to it.
Apes or monkeys in the same way that
monkeys are primates.
Humans are apes and I am a human.
It's called the nested hierarchy.
That's right.
It means that all apes or monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes,
just as all humans are.
Abe's,
but not all apes are humans.
Okay.
Yeah.
Zygoma per click on that link.
They get someone's website at.
Yeah.
This is what I read.
Now,
is this a.
Is this a bullshit article?
I don't know.
Sorry.
Apes or monkeys deal with it.
That's another term.
I don't know the origin of the term.
Mark martin robbins wrote a fun piece to
the lay scientists the other day,
the incorrect term.
These monkeys described apes.
It triggered an article by graham smith
for the daily mail.
In martin's words,
a great crime against entry is in
progress and it's time for someone to
draw a line.
So as a parent,
how do yoU say that pen
today?
Antic.
Yeah,
but I never stood by itself,
uh,
with a professional interest in the
issue.
I'm taking my stand to help ensure the,
that a miscarriage of pedantic
justice doesn't occur.
That guy likes that word.
Um,
nested hierarchies.
Apes or monkeys in the same way that
monkeys are primates.
Humans are abe's.
And I'm a human,
it's called a nested hierarchy and he
has a primate nested hierarchy setup.
Could be right.
I just don't know.
I don't know the origin of the term,
but he cares and he cares enough to put
that up.
Yeah,
he fucked my head up.
Just dude.
You could be right or not right.
He's,
if anybody's right,
he's right or you're right.
No,
no knowledge.
But all I mean is that.
So the ancestors who moved to the
savannah weren't monkeys like baboon
monkeys,
chimp,
ancient chimp.
And so once we get tome erectus,
they're Basically like us,
although there are brains there around
nine 60 were around 13,
15 and we literally have a chimp brain
added on top of there.
So There's a big difference and you're
absolutely right.
It's accelerating like crazy.
And I am totally convinced.
Well I believe rang gms,
right?
I mean we don't know for sure of course,
but I believe he's right,
that it was fired.
They played a huge role in that.
And so what you got is this process,
where are our evolution facilitates a
further evolution,
right?
So you get the cognitive capacities to
control fire and now that allows you to
grow your brain even larger.
Because we can,
we can store fat,
we can get more nutrients from the food
we eat,
we can detoxify other things.
Fire super valuable.
Even chimps will eat if they go through
a area where there's a forest fire and
you know,
speaking to what's going on locally,
they'll eat like the roasted nuts first.
They really liked that because I mean,
you know,
just you go in your kitchen,
you smell a raw steak.
It's like palatable.
You smell it when it's cooking.
It's delicious or that is interesting,
right?
That's us.
No salt or anything on our nose telling
us that is a great source of food and
nutrients.
That's not so much.
That is interesting.
I've never thought about it that way,
but yeah,
there's a tremendous difference in the
way your body reacts to it and it's not
just based on your experience eating it.
It just smells amazing.
It smells amazing and so random talks
about.
he argues that you can't live on a diet
of raw food unless you're reading these
super fruits and stuff like that,
that basically we've horticulture into
existence because raw food just doesn't
give you enough calories.
So the example that he uses,
which is a great one,
is chimps literally spent something like
six to eight hours a day chewing just to
soften up the food enough so that they
can swallow it and digest it.
You know,
if sushi you're hardly,
you know,
some of the things that we cooked and
that's all in that case,
but you know,
cooked steak,
I really nice one.
You barely chew it at all.
It's just down the hatch.
It goes.
So that's a great argument for gorillas
as well,
right?
Because gorillas are just eating roots,
fucking celery and so literally they
have a humongous got right constantly
chewing in order to me and they've got a
huge,
the sagittal crest right here with the
bone so that the muscles attached to it
so they can chew hard enough to get
through all that stuff and make a
digestible and still there.
God is enormous.
Yeah,
that is interesting.
The chimps have those enormous chewing
muscles on their head and so we lost.
That's another example where somebody
along the way last,
I can't remember what that gene was,
where our muscles weakened in our jaw
and that would have been a year.
That would have been a death knell if
you're back cooking,
right
post cooking.
All that does is free up space for get
rid of some unnecessary muscle,
free up morris cranio space for brains,
the inside,
not the outside,
so is it likely that there was a bunch
of different factors that there was
natural selection in play and that there
was also the the throwing arm and then
also cooking and also this,
this cooperative effort that led to
people being a little bit more
ingenious,
a little bit smarter and how they hunted
and how they tried to get food and then
how they protected their fire,
how they cultivated fire,
and that all these things lead to more
clever behavior which led to a natural
selection of clever,
more clever champs with larger brains
are apes rather with larger brains?
Absolutely,
and so anytime you got something major
happening,
it probably doesn't have a single cause,
it probably has lots and lots of causes
and so in this case all these kinds of
factors came together.
Now if you're standing at the outset and
you're playing god and saying,
well,
let's see what happens when I dry out
the rain forest,
I think nine times out of 10 the chimps
all end up dead,
right?
But somehow we got really lucky and they
went down this very particular road and
once they got their social act together
and they started cooperating,
chimps are never going to be very
effective in groups because they can't
get along.
They can cooperate very well,
but,
but once these animals probably had us
fill a pivot,
gus,
but maybe not till later.
Of course we don't know all we can look
at what they were capable of,
but it fits the storyline that they
would have been the ones who develop
that.
Once that happened,
social becomes everything.
So we tend to think about what are the
challenges of physical life like sago
palm.
You move into that territory and you got
to configure that out.
It seems enormously complicated,
but you have to remember that before
modern travel was invented,
everybody walked everywhere which meant
you spent your entire life basically in
territory that you're familiar with or
the kinds of animals that lived there,
the kinds of problems that you face and
so cognitively the terrain is not really
a challenge for you and how to even
making food in those really complicated
ways is not a challenge for you.
Once you got theory of mind and you can
learn how to do it,
but what is a huge challenge for you is
the social interactions with each other.
Because as my group gets smarter,
if I'm not smarter for sole member,
we talked about sexual selection.
I'm not going to get picked.
I'll get left behind.
Second of all,
we live in a world where there's no law
enforcement,
and so the day that you decide that I'm
more troubled than I'm worth,
I'd go to sleep on.
I never wake up again,
and so I have to be able to manage some
very complicated relationships.
It's a little bit in my mind,
it's like every morning when you wake
up,
it's to an episode of the sopranos.
How are you going to find a way to get
through your day without getting
whacked?
Right?
And if you can't figure it out,
that's the end of your life.
Have you ever read any terence mckenna?
I know you're familiar with something
called the stoned ape theory.
No,
sorry,
not mckenna.
It was,
uh,
he was,
an ethnobotanist and he was also a
psychedelic adventure and he had a
theory.
And the theory was that the,
what you're talking about,
this climate change that also coincided
with a doubling of the human brain size.
His theory was that one of the things
that was
in play was that these apes would
experiment with different food sources
as they moved into the grasslands and
there was a lot of undulates and these
grasslands and it siliciden mushrooms,
which we know existed back then would
grow in these grasslands and that these
monkeys,
apes rather started consuming siliciden
mushrooms and it led them to be more
creative.
And it also led to specific traits like
the development of language that eating
mushrooms in low doses increases visual
acuity,
which would lead them to be better.
Hunters are more perceptive.
It also leads them to be hornier,
which would most likely involve more
breeding,
more sexual activity,
and possibly select the ones that chose
the mushrooms would maybe possibly breed
more than the ones that didn't choose
the mushrooms because they were more
into it.
And then we're more social,
more sexually active.
And he has a series of,
uh,
like his brother dennis,
who's still alive,
detailed it on a podcast we did the very
first podcast we did in his brother is
an,
as is an actual scientist.
And detailed it in terms of how silicide
affects the brain and what areas of the
brain it,
what,
what actually takes place when you're
under the influence of this and that it
could very potentially have led to the
development of language and that this,
all these things in play,
the throwing arm,
the developing these new social
networks,
uh,
where you need to communicate with each
other along with the harnessing of fire
along with the consumption of
psychedelic mushrooms on a regular basis
because they were incredibly frequent
and very admirable.
Right?
That's total trip.
I've never heard of that.
Fascinating.
It would be really like,
that's a really good example of some
random thing if it really did play that
role,
how random that is,
that these freaking things happen to be
growing there and that they happen to be
attracted to them and ate them.
We know that animals like to get high.
I'm elephants will eat these fruits that
have well the drunk in this case,
overripe and,
and have become alcoholic.
We know that animals will do that.
you've seen jaguars that consumed
psychedelic plants and they rely on
their back and stare at the sky and no.
Oh,
it's amazing.
But you know what iowasca is?
No.
Iowasca is a,
it's a way that,
uh,
these people in the rain forest develop
untold thousands of years ago of
developing an orally active version of
dimethyltryptamine.
Do you know what their mental tryptamine
dimethyltryptamine is?
The most potent psychedelic known to
man.
It's incredibly potent drug that is just
intensely hallucinatory.
Gives you these insane visions.
And it also is this.
Here's a jaguar.
It's really crazy.
And this is in the amazon.
These jaguars eat these plants and
plants are the,
they have the ingredients of iowasca and
these jaguars are known to eat these
things and then trip her fucking balls
off.
they eat them and there are pupils
dilate and they roll over on their back
and stare at the sky.
I mean,
they're clearly high.
So this is something that you're going
to say,
yeah,
this is what I'm gonna say.
So this is what iowasca is,
is dimethyltryptamine look kind of cool
watching this jaguar trip balls.
They just stare.
They see shit that's not there,
I mean,
or it is.
They're still traveling.
It's amazing.
So what iowasca is is w,
there's dimethyltryptamine,
which is this incredibly potent
psychedelic drug is produced in the
human body.
It's produced by the liver.
It's produced by the lungs,
and they also believe it's produced by
the pineal gland,
which is literally your third eye,
the pineal gland in certain reptiles
actually as a rep,
a retina in a lens.
I mean it's like an eyeball and they
think that the egyptians called it the
seed of the soul and they think that
this is one of the reasons why they have
this obsession with this gland in
eastern mysticism is somehow or another,
they figured out that this is the gland
that produces this incredibly potent
psychedelic truck.
This psychedelic drug dimethyltryptAmine
also exists in thousands of different
plants.
The problem is when you consume it
orally,
your body produces something in your gut
called monoamine oxidase,
and monoamine oxidase breaks it down.
So what these indigenous people figured
out is how to combine one plant which
contains this psychedelic compound with
another plant which contains a natural
mao inhibitor called harming.
So they brew this all together,
much like they did the cassava,
which we have no idea how they figured
that out.
They bring this stuff up together and
they create this psychedelic t called
iowasca and iowasca.
Now they have all these trips where
people go down to Peru and take this
stuff and trip to fucking balls off.
And this,
uh,
this,
the combination of these things leads to
this incredibly potent trench,
really transformative experience,
which is impossible to describe and that
this,
this psychedelic drug.
Why?
Why did I bring that up?
Was what we were talking about how maybe
chimps and are these early ancestors did
something similar which pushed them
along this path that starting to
communicate.
How did I get it?
Wow.
How did I get the iowaSca?
There are a couple of links in that
chain is because of animals that get
high.
That's,
that's what it was.
So this is what this.
That's exactly what it was.
It was,
yeah.
The jaguar getting high on dmt,
that's what they think.
The jaguar,
it's the jaguar consuming this stuff.
It's making them trip on dmt.
Dmt is.
I mean it's fun.
it's really exciting.
And so that's.
So robert trevors is wonderful biologist
who started a lot of the kinds of work
that we're talking about going in the
seventies,
calls these sorts of things of
phenotypic intelligence,
right?
So evolution gave you these pleasure
centers in your brain so that you do in
your genes best interests and kill the
animal or get the girl or whatever and
that makes you feel good.
And so we tend to like the things that
are good for us in dislike,
the things that are bad for us.
We don't want to eat feces,
we do on a to stick.
So there's cases like this where it
short circuits that it goes right to the
pleasure center.
Even though what it's doing,
it's kind of irrelevant,
but this is a case where maybe it wasn't
irrelevant.
Maybe it actually causes animals to then
change the way that they behave to
become more sociable.
Right.
It's very possible.
Something like that played a role along
the way,
which is why if you replay the sequence,
the vanishing rainforest 10 times,
only one time does it maybe lead to
anything good and the other nine times
that leads to a bunch of dead chimps.
Yeah.
Well the the process is probably
incredibly slow,
right?
Over millions of years of the climate
did alter was right,
so you've got millions of years for the
rain forest to disappear,
so you get these animals to slowly,
slowly say,
I've got no choice.
So they figure it out and then I think
for three and a half million years,
literally there's skulking around the
edges and they figured nothing out,
but there was a pressure on them to walk
up.
Right.
And nobody knows for sure what that
pressure is.
One hypothesis that has some possible.
There's probably a lot of reasons,
right?
Any time something big happens is
probably a lot of causes.
So some people said that you can cover
ground more efficiently when you walk
up.
Right?
With fewer calories,
and especially this idea of slowly
running down animals.
You may have heard about this notion of
persistence hunting exactly and talked
about that yesterday.
And so,
um,
the uh,
but another reason is so ask yourself,
so why would an animal,
so if we back up a little bit,
remember I talked about how older one
tools which are made even later than
when we first started walking upright.
So there even after that,
all the tools are never carried it.
Integrate distance from where they are
acquired inmate.
And so what you have is an animal,
just like today's chimps,
they can't plan for tomorrow.
So a chimp can plan for needs that are
currently feels,
it can say,
oh,
I want to go get 'em termites out of
that mound all break the stick off.
I'll strip the leaves and then I'll go
over there and do that.
But it can't plan for the fact that it
might have that need again tomorrow if
it doesn't feel the need can plan for it
and humans can plan for unfelt needs.
And the best example of that is notion
of taking a tool with you that you've
now used in st.
Well,
I want to use it again tomorrow,
right,
so whichever.
Also a pythagoras was the first one to
start walking upright was almost
assuredly incapable of planning for the
future for unfilled needs,
but it could plan for felt needs because
the chimp can do that too.
And if you think about how would you
feel if you're about to walk across the
open savannah and you're kind of small
and leopards and lions are way faster
than you.
I think the primary thing could feel his
fear like,
oh shit,
I'm going to get attacked and so I want
something in my hands to help me defend
myself.
Let's be.
You're a club,
a stick something.
And so what I suspect is a part of the
process is my desire to hold something
in my hand as I'm looking around and I'm
scared and a bunch of us are doing that
and so I suspect that that's what led to
played a role in leading to bipedalism.
There would have been other factors at
play like persistence hunting and stuff,
but I suspect that came later.
So whole actually
holding a weapon might've led to the
beginning of that just because you don't
need to be a rocket scientist.
You're scAred now.
You want something to defend yourself.
Do we have evidence of them sharpening
sticks?
Will remember.
So modern chimps who live on the
savannah do sharpen sticks.
Modern.
yeah.
What do we have evidence of ancient man
and we don't even.
We don't even have sticks leftover for
rectus.
We know they must have used them because
they're making some pretty complicated
stones.
And so surely they were sharpening
sticks,
but all of it's decade.
So what year did we.
So we really don't know when they first
started attaching these stone tools to
sticks rail,
waking axes,
spears.
We know that that's happening very
recently by homo sapiens.
We don't know if it happened before
that.
If I had to guess,
I would say that homo erectus did that.
If you look at the quality of other
things that they've done.
So for example,
there's this amazing site off the sea of
galilee.
It's about 700,000
years old.
So member humans,
homo sapiens,
let's call it 300,000
years.
So now we're 700,000
or so years ago and there's this
elephant skull that's been turned over
so that they can get access to the
brain's friend.
This thing is unwieldy.
It's heavy as anything.
You got to have people working together
to turn that thing over and there's even
a log underneath it that might've been
used as a lever to kinda help plop thing
over.
So what you got is people are quite
capable of working together.
They know what they're trying to
achieve,
they know how to access those things.
I suspect that they knew that they could
sharpen the stake or maybe even have to
put a stone to make it even better.
It's just that we can't find any
evidence for that.
At least not yet.
He wasn't there.
Some certain really ancient evidence of
cannibalism too because of the scrape
marks inside of skulls and they think
that they were scooping out brain
matter.
That's possible.
I haven't seen those data,
but absolutely you can see where they've
used those tools on like the legs of
animals and things like that.
So you'd see it inside the skull as
well.
A human skull that,
um,
I'm sure you're aware of that little
person that was discovered just a few
years ago.
I think it was like a decade or so ago
that on Indonesia and a flores.
Yeah.
They think that little person type thing
using stone tools,
right?
Yes.
Those guys.
So remember there.
So what happened about one point 6
million years ago,
we'll call it one point seven,
I don't remember exactly.
homo erectus leaves africa,
but they also stay.
So you got home rectus basically
colonizing all of africa and you've got
homo erectus colonizing almost all of
europe,
all of southern asia.
And so they don't,
they don't go beyond that,
at least not to our knowledge.
Maybe they dId,
but um,
but they certainly covered all that
ground and an outside of.
So now you've got homo erectus in africa
and homo erectus outside of africa.
And of course then overtime,
both of them are going to evolve and
change the ones outside of africa and
depth as neanderthals.
Those,
the most recent recent instantiation of
them,
the ones inside of africa ended up is
us.
And so when we leave africa,
the first thing we encountered as
neanderthals in arabia,
because that's the first point of entry
out of africa,
and so we probably started copulating
with them there.
We know we started copulating with them
soon afterward.
So as we left they involved somewhere
else.
They evolved in europe and asia and so
they had evolved from some other type of
the same ancestors.
So our.
Okay.
Our great uncle left and our great
grandpa stayed.
And so the ones who left,
some of them evolved into those people
on flores to those tiny little people.
Some of them we know this,
dentists sylvan from a pinky bone,
you know,
in a cave inside Russia.
And we have got,
we know that we interbred with
neanderthals and that's where a lot of
our genes that we currently have for
light skin and blue eyes and things like
that come from and they think we
interbred with denisovans as well,
right?
Well not all of us.
So there's some,
there's evidence for melanesians if I
remember having dennis blood,
our dna I don't,
I don't know about.
so it may turn out that we did.
Um,
I don't think so though,
but there's no evidence that humans
interbred with the folks from flores.
Not that I know of.
I've never seen that.
They're tiny.
They're really good.
They're very small.
They're like hobbit.
Like now that doesn't mean that if,
if,
if we well know we would have.
It's possible that we could have
overlapped with them if somebody would
do it.
Yeah.
so like we hit,
we hit Australia by 65,000
years ago and I don't remember when the
floor is people we hit Australia at
65,000
years ago.
Wow.
And that was through some sort of boat
traveling.
So 65,000
years ago would've still been ice age
and so we would have had a lot less
water.
And so if you,
if you look at topographical maps then
when you look at what the pacific
islanders didn't stuff,
it seems ballsy as hell,
but it's a little less ballsy when you
can keep seeing the next piece of land.
Not not as far away compared to now
where the seed is much higher and you
can't see the land.
Oh,
okay.
So when the pacific islanders like
traveled to Hawaii,
you think they could see things?
Yeah,
they could see a lot better.
Now.
The most recent that the very last
place,
the pacific islander settled as New
Zealand.
That's only 700 years ago,
so that's the same as today.
But um,
but a lot of that discovery was done at
a time where the seed was a lot lower
and so there'd be a lot more islands
ticking up that we don't currently have
700 years ago they had much more
sophisticated boats.
Yeah.
That was awesome.
You records and all that.
Yeah,
it is crazy when you think about like
we're like little rats with the way
we've scattered across the globe.
And if you,
if you think about it,
it,
it seems like it's all ballsy
exploration,
but I actually suspect a bigger part of
it is running away from the guy behind
you.
It's causing problems.
And so my favorite example of that is if
you look at the cliff dwellings,
like in the american southwest,
and you go there and thinking who the
hell would live like this?
I mean,
you know,
when junior walks out there,
but if the people down in the valley are
scarier than the risk of falling outside
uk,
you're going to live up in a cave
dwelling where they're going to climb up
to get.
And that's part of the memory we talked
about sexual selection as a source of
people don't like unfairness.
Well,
people also don't like unfairness
between groups because if you and I make
a deal and you know,
I'm from Ohio and you're from California
and the California has benefit more than
the ohioans.
Even though my benefit,
you benefit more noW I'm at risk because
maybe your group,
you know,
ancestrally it's going to cause my group
problems.
Interesting.
So when
you're studying all this stuff,
how does that make you feel as a person?
Do you mean?
Do you,
do you.
Could you ever internalize all this
stuff when you're thinking about like
all the weird ape,
like creatures that turned into people
and all the thousands and thousands of
years of evolution and how it could have
gone left and it did go right.
And does That freak you out when you
really get deep into the study of all
this stuff?
It first of all,
I do this all the time,
right?
so it doesn't freak me out,
but it's what I like and it also,
we can talk about all the ways that you
can predict things about our modern
cells based on knowing these things in
the past.
Right.
But secondarily,
what freaks me out the most probably is
the enormous role of random chance and
all this.
Right?
And so if you think about the,
I mean,
just think about our own backgrounds,
the random chance that our mom and dad
got amaris the night that they did made
you and me if,
if they did a different position,
maybe your brother's talking to my
brother,
right?
Yeah.
So it's reAlly which sperm wins that
race is so unlikely to be us.
Right?
And so every roll of the dice has to go
your way.
Right.
And so the role of chance and all this
kind of freaks you out if you think
about that.
But at the same time your brother is
probably a lot like you and my brother
is probably a lot like me or my sister
or whatever.
And so you have one child or have more?
I've got a boy and a girl.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well you know,
then that they're so different right out
of the box,
which is really weird.
It is weird.
So I don't know if you saw this book,
the ploumen just wrote called blueprint
robert plomin who's a behavioral
geneticists.
I haven't seen that.
Our,
it's a lovely book.
Just came out and just really recently,
like a month or two at the most.
How do you say his name?
P l o m I n robert pillowman.
And um,
he's a wonderful behaviors geneticists
over in the uk and this book blueprint
talks about the role of genes and all
this.
And he,
he basically is one of these people
who's been in the field almost since it
got started.
And what they kept thinking is that the
environment was going to play a huge
role,
that parents were going to play a huge
but of course what they keep finding
over and over again.
there you go.
There's how dna makes us who we are and
what they find over and over again,
and this was so disconcerting,
is first of all,
on average,
most things are about 50 percent
genetic,
but the bummer is that the other half
isn't,
isn't what's happened in your house and
the way you're brought up by your folks.
It's the random other stuff like the
first,
we don't even know what it is.
It's just,
it's what we call unshared environment.
Maybe that first girlfriend you had,
maybe you biked into a tree and you
unimproved your face,
you know a million different things that
specifically happened to you that didn't
happen to everybody else in your family.
Right?
And also the way you address those
things that happen and that could have a
factor that could be a factor in how you
were raised and how you were taught to
deal with stress.
How you were taught to deal with
situations and character development,
but all the data suggest,
not suggest parents just don't matter
how you were taught doesn't seem to play
a role because when we parse up all the
different traits about you,
there's a few that your parents actually
have a big influence on what religion
you're in,
for example,
but not how religious you are.
SO the biggest role that you play seems
to be when sperm medic.
So a friend of mine,
the analogy they made when,
when I,
when I had my first kid is these,
he says,
here's what you're going to find out
that you're handed.
When the baby's born,
you're handed a negative.
It's the pictures already been taken.
You can screw it up by being in the dark
room a little bit wrong or you can help
it a little bit by being in the darkroom
a little bit.
Right?
But the photograph is already there and
my son and my daughter are wildly
different in some ways.
In some ways they're quite similar,
but I feel like I'm along for the ride
more than I feel like I'm shaping them
to make them who they are,
but don't you think you're shaping him
somewhat?
I'm trying.
Look,
that's what we do,
but the date is say no,
but how would the data?
No,
I mean,
so here's how we do
to study so many different human beings.
You have to.
You have to take into account all the
variables that took place during all the
developmental periods of their life.
Well,
the it to do it right,
you need to do all that and we can't do
that yet and to do it right.
What you want is actually to have that.
The actual genetic markers,
not just to know that the genes are
there and that's all starting now,
but.
But we don't know yet.
What they do do is they'll say,
well,
we got a bunch of where there's two ways
to go about this.
Employment was at the front of both of
them.
One,
you look at adaptive studies versus kids
who are adopted into a family versus
biological and you can compare the
parents of the adopted kids to the
biological parents versus the home
parents,
and it turns out that the biological
parents predict a whole lot more about
the adopted child than the parents who
raised them.
The parents were raised in predict
almost nothing.
Whoa.
I know,
and then the second thing you can do is
you can look at fraternal versus a
monozygotic identical twins and you find
that the when you then they all share
the same environment.
They're,
they're all brought up by you and me,
right?
Where the parents of these kids,
but the they also,
there's a lot of unshared environment
and that's when they differ.
It's not because of you and me,
we can't find any evidence that you and
me that you and I made any difference.
All we can find is evidence that other
things in their life made a difference.
Not to say that means what we really
don't know is,
well,
what is that unshared environment?
All we know is it's not something about
your household because that would cause
fraternal and identical twins to both be
more similar to each other and it
doesn't.
Well obviously a lot.
There's not a lot of data in terms of
when you're measuring someone's entire
life from birth to death,
but there's enough that people are
starting to draw conclusions.
One of the more interesting ones is when
you see identical twins that were raised
in different households without any
knowledge of each other,
and then they run into each other 30
years later and they find out they have
disturbing similarity.
YeAh,
that's exactly another example,
and what's also interesting about it,
which plum and talks about in blueprint
is that your genes become more powerful
as you age.
So the heritability of things like iq
goes up as you get older,
and so the argument is that your gene
seemed to be causing you to select out
environments.
So you gave the example,
well,
maybe the way that you discipline them
or tell them to be resilient or whatever
you do as a parent causes them to shape
their environment.
It doesn't seem to be the case,
but it does seem to be the case that the
genes that you give them caused them to
select their environments in certain
ways because remember,
kids choose their friends,
right?
You want them to play with timmy,
but they want to play with johnny.
That's,
that's the unshared environment.
They're making those choices every day.
It's also the case that their peers
matter a whole lot more than their
parents do once they get to a certain
age.
You know,
I'm chopped liver as soon as my kids are
a bit older,
but when I'm young,
I'm their hero right now.
When you.
When you say that your genes become more
powerful as you get older,
what do you mean by that though?
Well,
they,
they are more predictive of the outcome
and so if you look at the heritability
of iq when you're a kid,
it's lower than when you're an adult and
it's lower still than when you're an
older adult,
and so what seems to be happening to a
lot of our traits?
Probably almost usually.
Are you saying that like if you have
children as an older person,
it's charitable as the kids get older.
Sorry.
Okay,
so as a.
So if you look at the heritability of iq
when kids are two,
four,
eight,
10,
20,
60,
you find that identical twins come more
and more together as they age,
whether they're aging in the same
household or not.
And so There's something about selecting
your environment.
So like here's one kid who loves to
think of do puzzles and it's identical.
Twin loves due to the same and they kind
of get smarter their whole lives.
Here's another kid who's not interested
in that.
They have other interests and they go in
a different direction,
but when you're,
when you're the parent,
you can be busily pushing them to do the
things you want them to do and so
they're heritability is less strong and
there's,
there's lots of cool examples.
It's like when totalitarian governments
are eliminated in the school system
becomes more fair.
Heritability of intelligence goes up in
those societies because kids are now
more capable of selecting the schools.
they want to go to the environments that
they want to be part of.
Wow.
What we're.
We're so flexible.
It's so weird when you think about all
the various styles of civilization that
human beings exist in and thrive in.
Right?
And,
and for me,
that's the key.
So when a lot of people hear about this,
they sort,
it sounds like genetic determinism that
your genes are forcing you to be a
certain way,
but for me it's,
there's nothing genetic determinism that
you can think of about as a genetic
nudge.
Part of your nudge is going to come from
the dna your inherited,
but part of it's going to come from the
environment and part of it's going to
come from your own personal decisions.
So in my mind we talk about in terms of
your mind,
because that's what psychology,
but an easier example is your muscles.
You know,
some people inherit genes that if they
lift one,
wait once,
they're both other people's genes.
They have to work out a lot if they want
to gain anything,
but you can still decide I'm going to
work out a lot or I'm not.
I'm gonna eat these nutrients or you
know,
a lot of protein or not.
You can choose a lifestyle that leads
you to be more muscular,
less so.
it's partially choice.
It's partially environment.
It's partially that interaction between
your genes and environment,
which would make sense if you think
about how flexible we are.
AbsoLutely.
It has to be active that we are.
It has to be because human beings have
to learn how to survive in every
environment on this planet.
If we were mere cats or something,
well,
we got a certain way of doing things and
your genes can basically tell you what
to do and with mere cats there's some
really interesting experiments where you
can show your genes,
caused you to listen to one signal and
just follow that.
But as human beings,
your genes have no choice but to give up
control.
Once we went down this cognitive pathway
that emphasizes learning over inborn
instincts,
you know you've had a little ones.
You know they're worthless when they're
babies,
right?
Baby willdabeast gets up and off.
It can go run away from a lion.
Yeah.
It's just so fantastically complicated.
The developmental process from birth to
adulthood and that this is taking place
simultaneously amongst hundreds and
hundreds of millions of people with
varying results and all sorts of
different levels of creativity and
ingenuity and mathematical prowess and
literature and all these different
things that are being created by all
these different,
weird little ape creatures everywhere.
And there's so many different factors
that determine what this ape creature
becomes.
Right?
And that's one of the best things in my
mind about being a person.
So if like if you're a dung beetle,
you got one job in life,
push up all the poor and you can't push
a ball,
a poo,
that's three times your body weight.
well that's the end of the line for you,
right?
But if you're a human,
maybe you're big and strong,
maybe you're not.
Maybe you're really smart,
Maybe you're really creative,
you know,
there's a million ways to skin that cat.
And,
and the great thing about being in the
human is that any good at any of those
things,
there's a niche for you.
You will be beneficial.
And because we evolved to all work
together,
there'll be value in you,
you're my favorite barista,
you're my favorite,
whatever,
whatever you're good at.
And everybody's good at something.
And so the thing is that people worry
about the sort of upcoming genetic
revolution that it's going to be,
whether it's going to be the good and
everybody else,
and that's just not going to happen.
Because one of the things that we know,
and you'll see this if you look at
blueprint,
is that you have a kazillion jeans on
july.
Every trait,
there aren't five smart genes.
There's like a thousand of them.
And furthermore,
each one of them only accounts for a
tiny,
tiny bit and they do lots of other
things too.
So you can't like,
you can't make a designer baby that has
all these qualities because all you do
is noodle around with five or six genes.
There's a couple of disorders that work
that way.
But our personalities,
our abilities,
our proclivities are all heavily
determined by large numbers of genes
that do lots and lots of different
things.
But we're talking,
talking about our understanding of
genetics currently.
Yes.
And when you talk about things like
genetic manipulation or the use of
crispr or any of these maybe new tools
that they're working on right now,
they've already updated crispr.
They were crisper point two,
right?
When,
when this continues to evolve and more
and more innovation takes place in that
world,
don't you think they're going to get to
a point where they're going to
understand all the various factors and
genetics and they're going to be able to
create a person who looks like thor?
Well,
yes and no.
So in principle,
yes.
So you've got like,
I don't know,
3 billion base pairs in your dna and
most of those we all share all the same
ones.
So screw the ones that are shared.
We don't care about those.
All we can do is noodle around with the
ones that aren't.
Now what makes it complicated is that
most of the ones that differ between
people are actually non there in what we
now call the regulatory region.
We used to think of as junk dna,
but now we know.
Well,
think about a company,
a company that makes widgets,
doesn't just make widgets,
has to have sales,
avesta marketing and asset management,
and now we know,
well sure enough,
a lot of the dna that's not coding for
proteins is working with the other dna
to turn things on and turn things off
and there's 3 billion base pairs.
So there's that level of complexity.
There is outrageous,
right?
So,
but let's still some day we'll get it
right.
It's not you and I won't see it.
And and what we now know from these
studies,
g was studies a genome wide association
studies is that you can look at all the
very base pairs that very and you can
say,
all right,
which one of these things are correlated
with my outcome of interest?
And so you say,
oh,
education.
And they create what's called
apologetics score and you say,
let's predict how many years of
education you're going to get.
And sure enough,
the richer you are on average,
the higher your polygenic score is it
you're born into a rich family.
You probably have a higher apologetics
score,
but if you're apologetic,
score for education is lower than the
average for your thing.
You'll probably get poor across your
life if it's higher,
you probably get richard,
is that a gene for being smart,
for sitting there and doing what you're
told for self control like it could be
and there's a thousand things in there
and each one of them accounts for one
10th of one percent of the variants,
but what makes it complicated is that
whole set of genes also predicts how
artistic you are,
but in a different combination and it
predicts how friendly you are in a
different combination and so the the the
genes that do one set of things almost
always do lots of things and we have
very few traits through that.
don't have lots and lots of genes that
each play a tiny role underneath them.
The example ploumen gives in his book,
which I think is great,
he says,
we started out looking for golden
nuggets and we now realize we looking
for gold dust.
It's just lots of tiny stuff like that.
They're so in many ways when you're
looking at a one,
you know,
you talk about the human genome and our
genetic code,
we're,
we're really similar to computer
programs and that there's millions and
millions of lines of code and computer
programs,
but we know how to make computer
programs so we know what these will.
We don't need to know somebody smarter
than both of us knows how to make these
incredible,
you know,
that lead to operating systems.
But now we're writing codeS that we
don't understand.
So if you look at neural networks,
they'll be input levels in the output
levels in the fricking computer decides
how to mix those things together and we
don't even know what the it's done.
And two of them that are learning the
same thing might get there via different
mechanisms.
So by that idea or with it through that
idea,
wouldn't you think that artificial
intelligence could lead to the mapping
out of the human genome or rather the
altering of the human genome and mapping
out a different type of human
look?
In principle it could and,
and,
and it may and all I would say is that
you,
what we thought though is that there'd
be five smart genes that really matter
and the rest are trivial and so turn on
those five smart once everybody's going
to want that and there'll be five funny
jeans and we'll turn those on,
you know,
et cetera.
But there's not.
and so what that means is I got to
decide what,
imagine this future world where I'm
about to have a baby and I can crisper
the whole thing and I have to decide
what genes I'll say,
well I can make them smarter,
but then he's not going to be very
friendly,
you know,
whatever.
Right?
The old trade off against each other.
You could get the big dick gene,
but it doesn't exactly give them
glasses.
Exactly.
And so the thing is that it makes it.
So yeah,
we will get rid of things,
these single gene disorders that are
awful.
Right?
Right.
But we're not gonna I suspect we're not
going to noodle around with our smarts
and our personalitY because every single
change we make is going to have a
commensurate change somewhere else.
Oh,
well I can make a smarter,
but then he's going to be depressed.
And you know,
like that.
Yeah.
That,
that is a boy,
that the idea of playing god like that.
I mean,
that's,
that's really mean.
We are playing creator.
I don't even necessarily think we should
use the word god in that respect because
it's something that's already been
created.
But we're taking this life form and
radically altering it
and we can already do that and people
will start doing it soon.
And we,
like when I was a kid,
when we were kids,
ivf is playing god,
now it's a triviality that is,
that is crazy what we're do.
You don't think that this is gonna take
place in our lifetime that maybe Russia
and China is going to make some super
person,
not too many genes that play too small
of a role.
And so the thing is that the,
um,
it,
it's too hard to mess around with.
It's too hard to make the to to create
these things.
There's nO reason that you'd be a lot
better off if you just did selective
breeding and the reality is you don't
even need to.
People already assertively,
mate.
They already choose partners who were
similar to themselves.
If they value education,
the other person does two.
If they value athletics,
the other person does too.
That works so much better than anything
that we're capable of doing right now
and when you do these,
ge was studies with these polygenic
scores and you say,
oh look,
you're born into a social class and
suggested to it probably behind.
You're just kind of low and sure enough,
you get poor across your life.
You're literally accounting for three
percent of the variants.
You're barely explaining anything
because even though when we look at the
behavioral genetic studies,
we can say,
wow,
intelligence has 50 percent genetic.
We can't come close to finding the genes
that actually do that,
and part of the reason we don't know,
but part of the reason may be that first
of all,
it's course 50 percent environmental and
what those random things are.
We don't know and second think about how
you were 3 billion base pairs,
how many things,
maybe when those two are in place in
that one isn't in the third one can be
interactions that really,
really complicated levels where you're
almost dead infinite.
And so that's why I don't think it
happens when you and I around to see it.
I think you're probably right.
But then I just realized that things
like crispr,
which were invented by accident,
came out of nowhere less than a decade
ago.
I believe it was less than a decade ago.
Right.
It's super recent.
It's outside of the.
Okay.
And then if you really stop and think
about even the mapping of the human
genome,
it used to be an unbelievably difficult
thing.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
checking your genetics was
preposterously expensive.
Now you just spit into a little tube and
send it to 23 and me and they,
they tell you,
hey bro,
you
know,
someone in your family is from europe
and this guy's from asia and yeah,
and so I could easily be wrong that you
and I will see it and it's only 10 years
away because competition really,
it seems so hard right now.
But things that were competition the
impossible when I was in grad school,
you know,
the simple analyses we did with our data
in grad school,
it's just like a phone could do that so
easily now.
And we waited 24 hours for the mainframe
to give it back to us.
Kurzweil talks about that,
that we really don't see things in terms
of the exponential increase in
technology.
You know,
kurzweil believes all this is going to
happen,
plus more.
He thinks you're going to be able to
download your brain into a computer and
you know,
and he started ourselves and smarter
than me.
I don't know if he's smarter than,
you know,
he's definitely smarter than me and his
research has just turned on the world's
most powerful super computer designed to
mimic a human brain.
Won't think I was telling you about a
week or last week.
That sounds pretty scary.
Computer neural morphic computer just
got a big boost with a million core
supercomputer that took over a decade to
build.
Mother.
Yeah.
This is the beginning of a movie,
right?
Right.
It doesn't go well,
but here's the thing,
right?
This movie in this movie,
this is a whole room full of computers,
just like the apollo missions.
Use the room for a computer that can't
fuck with your phone and this was really
crazy.
That's 1965.
Sixty six,
67,
right?
They,
they had a room.
This iphone,
berries that room full of fucking shitty
ass computers and 10 plus it takes
pictures.
Do you remember when your kids and
everybody said everyone will have their
own phone and I'm thinking,
who the hell wants a phone?
Like my mom will just reach me wherever
I go.
She didn't know what a phone could do in
those.
Nice to have a bit.
And this is only from 2005 from a
netflix special I did in 2005,
which,
you know,
it's 13 years ago,
but doesn't seem like that long ago,
but I was making fun of people texting
because uh,
I was like,
hey bro,
why?
Why are you making me read?
Call me.
I go,
well,
you're sending me texts from a fall,
you will fucking call me.
It takes you four presses to get an s.
That was back when you had numbers.
Yeah.
And then that was also back when people
thought it was cool to have those walkie
talkies,
those nextel phones.
Do you remember that?
That was like a big deal to have a
walkie talkie on a phone that died out,
thankfully.
But this,
this whole change in the way we view
technology from 2005 to 2018.
The world is a radically different
place.
And the funny thing is that you and I
both make a living by observing the
human condition,
right?
That's our job and we both get it wrong.
Constantly write every day.
You got that?
The texting,
what the hell is that?
I remember my sister showed me facebook
because she was in an ngo and they're
using it to keep track of each other.
I was like,
yeah,
people don't want to do that shit.
I'm wrong.
Every time,
every single time I'm wrong.
I follow quite a few people on facebook
that are nuts and uh,
I go to their pages just to see what
kind of arguments or getting into like
as a sociological experiment.
And there are people that are on
facebook arguing about trump or abortion
or islam or fill in the blank,
environmental concerns,
fracking.
And they just fucking argue all day
long.
It's fascinating.
You look at their timeline,
you look at it,
the entries and you're like,
oh my god,
there's like 10 hours of this shit in a
day.
And they just do it all day long.
And you just picture this sweaty person
sitting in front of a computer arguing
with the world.
I never would have thought that there'd
be people sitting in front of their desk
arguing with people that they can't see
all throughout the world.
Who thought that?
Who thought that would be fun?
I don't think it is fun.
I think it's an impulsive,
obsessive thing that people get sucked
into and I think they're vastly
healthier and happier when they're not
engaged in it.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean the truth of the matter is,
and this comes back to the past again,
so you.
We talked about all of these
differences,
so one of the really lovely things that
you can do is look for the past and then
say,
well,
how does that manifest itself today?
And one of my favorite examples is the
whites of your eyes.
So chimpanzees have brown eyes.
The sclerA around the cornea.
Ours are white.
Why would you do that?
Well then advertise as the direction of
your gaze.
Why would you advertise the direction
case?
Because what that says is that on
average as a human,
when I look over there and see
something,
I want you to know that I saw it.
You and I are probably going to
cooperate to help us achieve whatever
the goal is that I just encountered.
A chimp wants to hide it from its fellow
chimps because it's competitive,
right?
On average,
whatever the hell is over there,
you're not going to help me get it right
or.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're gonna.
Make it harder for me to get it.
yeah.
The chimps ever did our amazingly,
amazingly groupers and octopi hunt
together and they do that.
Groupers and octopi work together,
the so the group will be over the great
barrier reef and the fish has gone in
and he goes to the octopus and he goes
right there.
No one reason.
He doesn't give a shit about the octopus
of course,
but if the octopus goes to get it and
doesn't get it,
it's going to come out and the group has
got it.
Cooperation always works better than
working on your own.
Right.
Wow.
So is there real evidence that shows
that the whites of our eyes developed in
order to indicate which way we're
looking?
Well,
in all these cases,
all we can do is say,
let's do a little phylogenetic analysis.
Who's got an and who doesn't?
We're the only great ape with whites to
their eyes.
So 90.
So we're going to look at it.
Get
this.
Here's an octopus that's chilling.
And is that a group or.
It's a weird look and spot it.
I guess.
I don't know really pretty.
It looks like a coral trout to me.
Oh man,
what do I know?
Look how pretty that octopuses too.
and they're really fucking love octopus
and they can change colors like that.
Yeah.
we've gone down massive rabbit holes
with these things for hours at a time.
Look at it is changing right now.
It's.
We're watching him,
so he's sitting there waiting and the
fish tries to get out and the guy that's
really cool.
The way they have the good sense to work
together.
Look at the octopuses matt.
It's getting dark.
Oh cool.
His skin is so.
It just changes and morphs as you're
looking at it.
That is so bizarre.
What a crate.
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't know that they could do this
until my friend remy warren came on the
podcast and he had a television show
called apex predator and within on the
show they would study all the various
ways these animals would hunt and the
way they would,
you know,
all the different adaptations to their
environment,
all the different ways that they would
use the environment and,
and he would try to mimic those
different ways and one of the things
that they studied was octopus and what's
that other fish that's like it.
The cuddle fish,
which is also the same thing.
Octopus is using a clamshell.
What is he doing?
He's lounging.
He found that he picked it up.
Oh my god,
there's a bbc.
This is crazy.
Oh my god.
The octopus is climbing inside of
clamshell and then he closes it.
That is bananas.
There's a bbc blue planet where it shows
the octopus picking up all that random
shrapnel when there's a shark coming
after it and it covers itself like a big
ball and the shark keeps going.
Wow.
They're super smart octopi.
Well,
they eat sharks.
You ever see that one?
There was a video where they found this
aquarium was having an issue with sharks
were disappearing.
They couldn't figure out what was going
on and they put a camera inside the
aquarium,
but it turned out that the octopus was
waiting,
just chilling on the rocks till the
sharks came by and then he would snatch
them and eat them.
Watch this.
It's really cool to watch.
He's like do to do to who?
Me don't bother with me.
I'm just a piece of coral.
I'm just hanging out here being clear
you like,
cause he looks exactly even in texture
like the coral,
which is so fascinating.
But when they found this,
they were stunned.
They had no idea that octopus could do
that.
Could not only that they could do that,
but that they would eat a shark and at
the big fight.
Fuck man.
It's not though.
You want to squeeze the thing first,
but it's an easy fight.
It looks like.
Is the thing about octopus though too?
They could sacrifice a technical and it
just grows back.
So really no big deal.
It's annoying,
but I don't even know if it's annoying.
I mean we're just guessing.
Right.
So there's a fascinating animal.
There's a rivet twisted them up.
It was an amazing case in Australia
where a coolant brown is a biologist,
had cuddle fish in this tank and they
can signal like an octopus octopus.
They can do whatever color and in this
tank he's got a bunch of females on one
side,
a bunch of males than the other.
So male goes in between them and he
signals to different sides of his body.
He shows a female,
he's male,
but he shows the males that he's female,
so they want to attack him for a sidling
up to the female.
Yeah.
How smart is that?
It's weird.
it's weird that they split off from us
hundreds of millions of years ago.
Right?
Like as closely related to salary.
Basically.
It's crazy,
but they're so smart and their eyes are
similar to ours and like in the
development
actually it's the opposite.
So there our eyes are poorly designed.
There's a very well designed so our eyes
have all the detecting stuff is in its
own way.
It's backwards and so the light comes in
and has to pass all the cellular bodies
before it can get picked up by the
detectors.
There's aim in the proper direction so
the shit isn't in the way and we have
this blind spot because the big thing,
the nerve connection,
they don't.
There's comes in from the back where it
belongs.
So what that tells you is that yeah,
we both started out with some kind of
randoms light sensitive spot and there's
happened to work much better if you want
to turn it into an eyeball than ours did
because evolution can always.
It only can start with what you got.
Right.
But there's work better because they
could see in water.
I mean,
no,
I mean because there I think it's purely
random that they don't have.
We do a great job of getting rid of the
segue of their bodies that are in our
way.
So what you're it does is it wiggles all
the time and so if anything's retinal
stationary,
it's wiggling and equally with your
eyeball you ignore it and so you don't
even know.
You have your own blind spot.
You feel it in your brain does amazing
things to fix the problem.
If you have a piece of lint on your eye
or something like that,
if it were literally attached to vinci
would disappear and because your brain
says,
oh,
that's irrelevant,
and so you can't see your own blind spot
unless you close one eye and then you
sit there with a neutral background,
you move your thumb across and literally
your thumbnail disappears because that
spot is just being filled in by whatever
the background and what happens with the
octopus.
It doesn't have that problem because our
nerve endings creates the bond spot by
being on the wrong side.
There's comes in from the back and so
the whole thing works beautifully.
They don't have to deal with the blind
spot.
Would that be as effective though in the
world that we live in?
Yeah.
It's a water area irrelevant.
It's purely,
it happenstance that the light sensitive
pit that they had started to get
innovated properly from the back and
ours didn't,
and then as ours evolved into an.
I mean,
of course we don't know this,
but as far as evolved tonight,
we just had to find ways around the
problem that all the fancy structures
that we now need in front of it or in
the way.
Does anything have an eye like an
octopus that lives on land?
Great question.
I don't know.
I don't see.
I've read something about eyes that they
think that I got shit information.
Now you're pregnant.
Memory that they have an amazing memory.
All these shows.
These still sore away.
That's too many shows,
man.
I don't have any memory anymore.
So it's like full.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm like a hoarder.
Like my house is filled with boxes of
shit that I don't need.
That's how brains work.
I'm afraid how brains work,
right?
I mean it must be because like I know
that there's a lot of stuff in there
that didn't use to be in there before,
but I also know like it's like random
people that I should remember that I
don't remember.
Yeah.
Well no.
The funny thing about brains is we may
never forget anything but we just lose
our capacity to access it,
but the data suggests it may still guide
our behavior and so every single
experience you've ever had may still be
in there and it guides your behavior,
but,
but it's use,
it's annoying for you to recall it
because it gets in the way of what you
want.
And so when we talk about forgetting
what we're actually talking about is
being able to actually retrieve it and
talk about it,
not to have it guide our action.
Well also I can,
I can retrieve things far better if I
get access the file
by someone else's memory.
So like if you and I had an experience
like 10 years ago,
we went on a camping trip or something
like that and I forgot something that
happened.
And you said,
do you remember what happened by the
creek when mike hurt his foot away,
right?
Oh yes.
Exactly.
Oh my god,
I forgot about that.
And then next thing you know,
you have this memory,
right?
and so what we've done is you've broken
the access in and so,
but if you,
you could literally find the sneakers
were go,
holy crap,
you know.
And so that's how our brain is designed
it,
it's,
it's annoying to retrieve when you're
looking for one thing to retrieve
everything.
If it's important or happened recently,
it probably should be retrieved.
If it's not,
let it sit away and it'll still got your
baby.
You won't put your foot in that same
hole when you and mike go on the camping
trip the next time.
But you won't even remember why.
Right.
And in likely significant lessons are
important because there are seared in
your memory of this is a,
this is a significant point where you
figured something out they didn't know
before and it changed the way you looked
at the world.
So this is seared in your memory.
Yeah.
And so when emotions get involved,
you tend to have,
it's much more easily retrieved later on
because your brain is saying,
yeah,
that's our evolution,
or whatever you wanna call it is telling
you that it's important that should be
retrievable.
And and what you had yesterday for
lunch,
I can never retrieve.
Right?
That's one of the reasons why
epidemiology studies on diet are so
difficult because people don't remember
what that day was.
The same thing every day.
Yeah.
It's,
the human mind is so fascinating and it
varies so much and there's so many
different factors involved and whatever
it becomes cultural factors and
environmental factors,
dietary,
and that's all that flexibility that we
evolved to put us in that special place
that we are.
And so we made a deal,
right?
So we said,
all right,
we're going to start going down this
cognitive pathway,
but that means that there's very little
inboard knowledge and that means that
we're going to have to learn from people
older than us and people with experience
there.
And that means that and the best way to
learn from them as high fidelity
copying.
And so if you happen to go off in a
direction where they use chopsticks,
well that's how you eat.
You happen to go in a direction,
that's how you eat.
There's a million ways to do things.
And so we started with the sort of
argument about,
well,
it wasn't monogamy or not,
right,
and the,
um,
I'm arguing that by and large it was
monogamy because you've got these
systems in place that our testicles
aren't big enough,
we've got cryptic ovulation,
which means that we can't tell when
she's fertile,
which means that we have to be available
sexually interested in available all the
time so we can make sure we're the
father.
And so that allows her to pair bond with
us.
And there's some evidence that orgasm is
a pair bonding experience,
certainly for females,
probably for males.
it works in lots of animals via oxytocin
and vasopressin,
all that kind of stuff.
Right?
So all that suggests that probably on
average that we evolved to do it this
way,
but we're so super dooper flexible that
went.
Another society says,
well,
hey,
this works for us.
Off we go and we find a way to make that
work.
Are there studies that compared testicle
size of different civilizations,
different cultures?
Yeah.
So there's a lot of argument about this.
And the problem is that the prince,
it's racist,
it's racist.
That's what underlies
a lot of it,
but we get this right,
so the thing is that that the,
the,
the genetics that explain why one animal
or one species would have large
testicles and other a small testicles
are not the genetics.
That would explain why two different
individuals in the same species would be
that way.
Because the only way to make that latter
one work is you have to inherit a
constellation of traits.
So if I'm an inherit the genes for big
balls and for impulsiveness and for
having lots of kids and not caring much
about him and all of the things that are
supposedly go with that,
that do.
When you look between species,
there's no way for the constellation of
traits to be inherited together.
Because remember I was talking about how
polygenic everything is and so they'd
all literally need to sit next to each
other on the chromosome.
If they've got any chance of being
passed on as a package and they don't.
And you also get all the shifting around
her.
In meiosis.
I can't remember the term for off the
top of my head,
but where the pieces of genetic material
move around and that virtually
guarantees that you're not going to
inherit this huge constellation of
traits within a species between species
is dead easy.
You know,
you're A species inherits big testicles
and inherits impulsiveness.
It inherits whatever,
uh,
and our strategy just reproduce it down
and ignore them in all that kind of
stuff's dead easy.
And so cim fathers don't pay any
attention to chimp babies to speak of
because while that's their mating
system,
right?
Whereas I'm,
you've got pair bonded gibbons and
things and now parents start to play a
much bigger.
Even male parents start to play a bigger
role,
but there's no studies that show that
human beings with archer testicles tend
to ignore their children.
Well,
so this is just that people have tried
to show that,
but here's the problem.
And tried to show that in studies.
So lots of people make that argument and
it's called life history strategies
where you say,
well,
you're going to develop one life history
strategy in these circumstances and
another and these other circumstances.
The problem is that you end up with
ethnic differences in testicle size,
which we know exist and you also have
ethnic differences in where in the kinds
of lives that people currently lead.
The difficult thing is it's super easy
to look at the world we are in right now
and this is what tripped me up earlier
as well.
You look at the world that we are right
now and assume,
well,
that's the way things have always been
and they haven't,
and so right now you know the
mathematics used for awhile.
They're the best math in the world was
taking place in the arabic world.
Now it's not anymore,
and so if you,
if you don't know that past,
you'd say,
well look,
people in the arabic world aren't as
good at mathematics and they have these
qualities and that you'd make an
inference.
Right now the ethnic differences in
testicles,
I believe,
but I can't promise you that.
it's some different.
West african groups happen to have the
largest testicle size on average.
Those west african groups tend to be
poorer right now.
There's lots of things about life that
go with being poor that looked like and
our strategy,
having lots of kids and paying less
attention to them,
but what you're probably looking at is a
coincidental association between some
biology and some part of some way that
your your people happen to live that
didn't exist a while ago and that won't
exist awhile from now and so it's really
easy to try to use this research which
people have to say,
well,
you've got primitive people who have big
testicles and low parental effort and
you've got some more sophisticated
people with smaller testicles and high
parental effort,
but that's genetically super naive.
One of the things that I learned when I
was in rome,
we took a tour of the vatican by this
guy who's a professor.
It was really interesting.
It was cool because we have a,
a really enthusiastic guide and who who
could explain a lot of things to you and
he was really excited that me and my
family were very curious about these
things too,
but one of the things that he said that
was really interesting.
I said,
okay,
I go,
why all the dudes have little dicks like
what's going on with that?
And he said that they believed that if
you had a large penis,
that large penises were a symbol of
barbaric behavior and that these were
crude or people and that to,
to be thought to be a sophisticated
person,
you wanted a smaller penis.
So they actually accentuated smaller
penises in their gods and smaller
penises in their statute.
And that's funny.
I mean,
you can see these kinds of things all
the time.
So early pre western contact.
Uh,
if you look At japanese women,
they're pins,
they're painted with their eyes as
narrow of a slit as possible post
western contact.
Now the women want more almond shaped
eyes and so they start painting them
with the beautiful women have bigger
eyes.
These things can change all over the
map.
I personally suspect that large penis
size is also a product of sexual
selection.
So it's more fun for her if he's got a
larger penis,
they're having sex for longer and more
regularly because is hidden.
So he has to be available at the time.
So she has to be available all the time
or the system doesn't work and that's
what creates pair bonding.
So humans copulating for a very long
period of time.
If you compare this to the other
primates with the single exception of
bonobos and we have way bigger penises
than any of the other great apes and I
suspect that that's something that is
female.
I mean women.
I would say why are men so obsessed with
the penis size?
But I suspect that there the creator of
it and that's why we're so obsessed with
it.
Women who say that are playing games,
they know that's ridiculous.
I don't know that they are.
they're definitely playing games.
That's like men who are saying,
why are women so obsessed with big
breasts?
We don't even care.
I've never met a guy who said that.
Some some asshole out there that's
playing games.
Okay.
Possibly.
You're right.
It is fascinating when you think about
all these different things that lead to
natural selection and the fact that
there's so many variables that are in
place and that we're trying to find out
what is better and what is not.
And if you have a study and this study
finds genetic differences and ethnic
genetic differences there,
there's,
there's a lot of blowback and a lot of
pushback against.
There will be.
And,
and one of the interesting things that
we do know is if you think about how
homosapiens evolved in africa and a
small percentage of us left,
which means the majority of us didn't,
right?
I mean there's few randoms who lived up
in the top right hand corner,
we're available to go,
which means that all the rest of the
earth comes out of a few small
percentage of the population that could
have left.
And so we now know there's enormous
genetic variation
within africa,
way more genetic variation within africa
than outside of africa.
Then between any two people are chinese
person in a norwegian prison are much
more closely related to each other
genetically then an african guy who
lives in the next village over.
And because most of the genetic
variability never left the continent.
And so we had this idea of race as if it
has genetic meaning and it doesn't.
But ethnicity does have genetic meaning,
right?
So an ethnic group evolved in a very
certain spot to deal with very certain
problems and their body shape will vary
and you've got these west africans or a
really jacked with these big muscle,
a lot of quick jerk musculature.
You don't see that over on east africa
very much.
Um,
you've got a tall people in Denmark you
don't see that,
you know,
in other parts of europe,
etc.
So people are the adaptation with the
nun to deal with the cold climate.
Exactly.
Also,
and lots of that sanitation and a lot of
that's just random genetic drift,
a founder population,
the other causes that aren't evolved but
nonetheless have a big impact on what
the population ends up looking like.
It's just so amazing to consider that
this entire species essentially,
except for the times that We interacted
with,
uh,
interbred with neanderthals came from
one part of africa,
you know,
that's one of the reasons why racism is
so preposterous because we're
essentially all africans.
We are all africans.
We've all of us who are out have a
little bit of other stuff in the us,
but just a tiny bit,
which,
so weird though.
We're so,
we're so much like dogs,
you know,
like a great dane can breed with a
poodle.
They DoN't look Anything like each
other.
So were from another planet.
You go,
well that's definitely true.
or that's not gonna happen.
It's like if you looked at lebron james
and um,
you know,
traci lords,
right?
They look like two different things.
They really do.
And I suspect that when we ran into
neanderthals were like,
oh,
she's kind of interesting looking,
sort of hot,
sort of different.
And so it,
you know,
first of all we know humans will
copulate with almost anything that old,
stale.
Yeah.
And things that aren't even alive.
Things that aren't alive.
Things,
the things that they probably shouldn't
be,
et cetera.
But the end athol ones are interesting
because really they are cousins.
They're cousins separated by a million
years and some change.
And um,
and if we don't know too much about them
either,
which is really weird,
we know they had larger brains than us,
but we don't really know how smart they
were now.
And,
and,
and why did we replace them?
Yeah.
Like did we,
was it diseases we carry that wiped them
all out,
was it we were better organized.
So we got rid of,
we all competed them.
We killed them on purpose,
you know,
if there's a million branch species,
we happen to know a lot about
neanderthals because they are existed
until very recently.
But wHat we do,
there's all sorts of branching that took
place early on,
lots of different australopithecines,
et cetera.
All those are dead ends and you know,
the fact that we're the only one that
comes out of that could mean,
well we got lucky or were me in this
shit and we took care of all of our
cousins who didn't,
you know,
we wanted what they had.
I think the ladder.
Yeah.
Probably a bit of both mean.
Well,
I mean that doesn't make sense.
That were mean to shit a million years
ago.
We're mean,
Shit.
Exactly,
and what's so interesting is,
you know,
this is something that coming back to
the point I was making earlier about us
cooperating,
so we evolved
to cooperate with each other,
but the key is we did not evolve to
cooperate across different groups,
so once you get to homo erectus and now
you've got division of labor and you've
got the capacity to plan for unfilled
needs,
right,
where they're carrying these issue lean
tools with them over great distances,
et cetera.
Well now who's your most effective
predator?
The occasional mammoth or saber tooth
tiger will have killed the occasional
one of us,
but they can't possibly take us on the
same way we can take them on.
There's only one other thing on the
planet that can take us on and that's
ourselves.
So other groups of homo erectus would
have probably been a major threat.
Certainly by the time we're homo
sapiens,
other groups would have been our only
major threat,
and so we evolved to be kind to each
other within our group,
but we did not evolve to be kind outside
our group.
That doesn't mean we evolved to be mean.
We evolved to be neutral,
so let's see if you're going to be
friend or foe and um,
and that neutrality,
super important.
It has the potential for cooperation
across group boundaries.
We can change women and men can mingle
so we don't interbreed too much amongst
ourselves.
We can trade with each other.
Lots of good things can happen.
But the second you guys get a little bit
aggro with us,
you know,
now we're in a position to just go all
out and try to exterminate you.
And so rang him as he's great data.
Richard wrangham,
same catching fire guy shows that if you
look at the rates of violence within
human groups compared to chimps to like
500 times more violent,
physically aggressive than we are,
you look at the rates between human
groups equal,
they're the one to one ratio.
So we tend to think about,
well,
how could it be that we're both so nice
and so mean,
but we have to remember that we evolved
to cooperate and to be nice to each
other,
to be more effective killers.
It wasn't because let's make a hippie
paradise.
It's like,
shit,
these lines are going to eat as you and
I got to have to get together to sort
out these guys,
and so our cooperative nature is
literally the flip side of the coin of
our competitive violent killings.
Nature.
Also the undeniable history of
unbelievably ruthless tribal warfare
would indicate that we have a long
history of fighting against others that
are like us that we don't know.
Absolutely.
When when hunter gatherers meet each
other and they do come into conflict,
which is a huge percentage of the time,
they literally fight to the death
because if you capture me,
you're going to torture me to death.
If I'm female,
you're gonna.
Incorporate it into your system and then
it's going to be okay.
Not great,
but okay,
but if I'm male,
I'm going to die so I might as well die
fighting you now because I'm going to
die on pleasantly later and that's super
common.
That's everywhere we see it and there's
tons and tons of bodies that are
healthily perforated that are the
clearly the consequences of this kind of
wharf.
Crazy that is thought to be even in 2018
and inevitable part of being human
being,
I mean warfare even to this day is
thought to be inevitable because there's
no,
I mean we would all love that one day
there'll be no warfare,
but there's no indication whatsoever
that that's taken
not almost there and I actually,
I think pinker has got the best answer
to this question which is basically,
well,
what structures do you need to put in
place to make the world a safer and less
violent place?
And,
and I don't knoW if you've talked to him
about his book better angels of our
nature.
I know you've talked to him about more
recent ones,
but
yes.
Better angels is a great example.
It's a great book.
It's a great example of how we become
less and less violent and even over our
lifetimes.
And,
and part of that is undoubtedly better
governance structure and all that.
But part of that I think is cycles on
itself.
So when I was a little kid,
and this kind of thing probably happened
to you,
I was on when I was in kindergarten,
the guy who drove our car pool was a
cop.
So this cop is driving me home in the
back of his car.
Now he's got no seat belts because this
is 1969 and cars don't have seat belts,
right.
Big bench seat and a buick or something.
And we'd come around a corner and they
all slide up against me to the edge of
the car seat and I'm trying to push
back.
But I'm this little guy,
right?
And I can't.
Then I hit the,
I mUst have hit my elbow against the
door,
flies open.
I rolled out of the car.
Oh my god.
And I go bouncing across the street.
Right.
So he's,
you know,
he's not going to arrive home empty
handed.
So of course he goes and retrieves me
from the ditch and he brings me home,
shows my mum and I'm bleeding and
bruised and torn shIrt and you know,
like you'd expect from bouncing out of a
car.
And my mom who's a pediatrician.
So she could tell I wasn't badly
damaged.
It looks to me over and says,
hi,
he looks fine.
Don't worry about it.
Can you?
Can you imagine somebody brought your
kid home?
Said,
hey man,
I'm really sorry joe.
Your daughter fell out the car and
bounced across the street to a throttle
them.
It'd be freak out and that's not that
long ago either.
No,
this is 1969 when you and I are both on
this planet and so what I think is part
of what's what pinker's documenting is
as the world gets safer,
we start getting used to a low mayhem
world and these,
these mayhem event stand out in our
minds and so it actually self
perpetuates where the safer it gets,
the safer we needed to be because every
little thing that goes wrong stands out
in sharper relief.
Very fascinating way Of looking at it.
You know what's interesting to me about
pinker's work is how much pushback he
gets and particularly about the world
being a safer place.
Like people want to keep putting
pointing towards violent episodes and
and racism and crime and all these
different things is different factors as
if it's some sort of evidence against
what he's saying when he's incorporating
that,
those Current events into this large
database.
And he's saying yes,
it's not that we don't live in utopia,
but the woRld is vastly safer and better
now than it was a thousand years ago or
10,000
years ago or even 100 years ago or even
if there's.
Why is there so much pushback
against this.
So the thing is,
I think what's going on as that people
worry that it doesn't look like a
problem to be solved anymore.
Right?
So when you.
When our kids,
we both have lots of gay friends,
but we didn't know it because they're
not telling anybody because someone's
going to kick their ass if they knew
that they were gay.
Now,
yes,
gay people are still discriminated
against,
but it's so much better than it was
then.
What you don't want to.
What I think people are advocates don't
want to say as well,
there's no problem anymore because then
you can allow them to still run into
troubles in various circumstances.
Even though the trouble they run into
today is a thousand times less than the
trouble they ran into and read little
same thing holds for racism.
Same thing holds for sexism.
They've all gotten so much better,
but and sexual violence is a perfect
example.
You know if you look at,
if you set,
this is in pinker's book,
if you set rape and homicide to you call
it both of them,
whatever level they are in 1970 to 100
and then you track them through to the
early two thousands on homicide is in
the uS.
homicides dropped down to like 50 rapes
dropped down to like 25,
but if you listen to women's advocacy
groups about campus sexual assault and
stuff,
you'd never know that and the reason you
wouldn't know it is because people
worry.
Well,
if you think the problem's getting
better on its own,
then you won't keep doing anything to
help fix it.
And that's a really unfortunate part of
our psychology because it makes people
feel like there's been no progress and
when you feel like there's no progress,
then you think,
well maybe we need to completely
overturn the whole system and try
something new.
And that's of course the point of
pinker's newest book,
enlightenment.
Now no things are going fricking great.
Turning anarchy and all of those things
are really bad ideas.
Voting for somebody like trump's a
really bad idea because things are
actually running along really nicely.
It's just that we tend to forget it
because every advocacy group who's all
worried about whatever their particular
issue is,
doesn't want the word to get out that
things are a lot better than they used
to be.
Because I think at some fundamental
level they think,
well,
25 grapes here isn't bad enough.
We better say that there's 100 or you
know,
I'm not saying they do this consciously,
but of course 25 reps here,
whatever the number is,
is bad enough.
Right?
It doEsn't.
It doesn't have to be the numbers that
it used to be when I was a child to be a
problem at all.
That has to be as a number above zero.
Well,
there seems to.
The people develop this vested interest
in promoting an idea and they want to
exaggerate that idea.
Whatever it is,
whether it's the idea that the world is
a safer place than it actually is,
or whether it's the world as an idea of
a more dangerous,
more dangerous place and it really is
and for whatever reason,
once we have it in our mind that this is
the thing we're married.
Two were married to this concept of
polyamorous life and that this is a
natural way to live or that you know,
violence is inevitable and then this is
just a part of who we are.
We tend to promote that and we tend to
have massive confirmation bias and it's,
it's.
I think it's because we personally
associate ourselves with ideas.
We don't look at ideas as being a thing.
Like if you think that something is one
way and then you're pointed towards
evidence that you're incorrect,
you feel like personally you've been
slighted,
or your being somehow,
somehow you're being diminished by your
lack of being.
Correct,
but you're incorrect assumptions and
notions.
You're absolutely right.
That is a weird part of being a person.
It's a very weird part of it being a
person.
It's the hardest part about being a
scientist because every good scientist
is wrong all the time.
I've been wrong already on your show.
Right?
And so it's super hard to admit it
because by human nature you just want.
You want.
My immediate reaction is to fight
against it and not say,
well,
hold on.
What's joe saying?
No,
he's right.
I overstated that.
Let's back off.
Right?
And so there's this really lovely paper
that came out in 2011 by mercier and dan
sperber,
and what they argued is,
I think they nailed it and they said,
here's what it is.
Our Brain actually evolved our logical
processing abilities not to find out the
truth of the world,
but to convince you of my point of view.
And so with oUr logical abilities
evolved in
service of persuasion,
not in service of seeking out the truth,
because of course,
if I can persuade you that the world is
the way it would in a way that benefits
bill,
that the world is something about the
way bill wants the world to be is true,
then the world's going to be a little
kinder to me.
It'll fit my worldview and others will
give me the things I want.
And so I go through life trying to
persuade you of my worldview rather than
trying to find out what's actually out
there.
And so that's why you think,
oh well smart people are going to fall
for that.
No smart.
It doesn't matter how smart you are,
you,
you're using whatever brain power you
have.
Not defined the truth,
but rather to find evidence for your
particular point of view.
Well,
I think,
I think it's also a byproduct of
ignorance because for the longest time
you could tell me something and there
was very little way that I could find
out whether or not your writer,
I really couldn't.
No,
you're correct.
Unless I went and started doing research
and read some books and whereas now I
could just pull up my phone and say,
hey,
bill just said this,
is that right?
And then the phone wIll go,
no,
there's been 100 different studies that
show that,
and you go,
oh look,
motherfucker,
I got the stats.
That's true,
and that definitely matters a lot.
It's this awesome democratization of
knowledge,
but if that really were all that it was,
then everybody would agree on their
politics.
Everybody would agree that the fake news
was fake and the real news was real.
Not necessarily because this is a fairly
recent invention,
but what I'm getting at is that I think
that the ability to be deceptive was
perhaps there was an evolutionary
advantage.
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah,
so that's one of the very first thing
that happens when you have theory of
mind,
because as soon as I realized the
contents of your mind differ from the
contents of my own,
I say,
oh,
I can plant something in joe's mind
that'll help me.
That ain't true,
but if he believes it is,
life will be better for me.
And so as soon as kids learn theory of
mind,
at age four,
they start to lie.
And prior to theory of mind,
they tell the truth when it's like,
where are you playing?
Hide and seek.
I'm right here,
dad.
You're supposed to keep quiet.
But they can't because they don't
understand that you don't know the same
things.
They know,
right?
Yeah.
And they also understand that they could
perhaps change the way you feel about
them by manipulating the truth relating
information.
It's what's weird is having kids and
seeing kids grow up and troubled homes.
One,
one thing you see almost universally is,
are those kids lie a lot,
you know,
because you're in the no choice
condition,
right?
Yeah.
You're in a bad spot.
And like one of my daughter's little
friends is constantly lying,
but you know,
she has a broken home and the
situation's not good and it's just,
it's unfortunate.
But this little kid is tormented because
of it.
She's always making stuff up and all the
other little girls roll their eyes and
they know she's a liar and it's.
IT's sad.
But the ability to be deceptive,
I feel like that,
you know this,
there's some sort of idea that we cling
to that if you can deceive someone about
certain particular aspects of your mind
or your past or what you've,
what you've accomplished or what you're
capable of doing,
that you will have a better place in the
social chain.
No,
that's absolutely
right.
And so the way I think about it is think
about the difference between conspecific
conflicts,
conflicts between members of the same
species and conflicts between predator
and prey.
So every time predator and prey
interact,
eventually one of them's going to die.
Your editor's going to starve,
praise going to get eaten,
right?
But when conspecifics members of the
same species interact more,
competing over something,
even if it's a very subtle level of
competition,
we don't want to come to blows because
if I'm trying to size you up,
be it physical blows or mental blows.
We suffering on both sides.
If we have to do get out.
And so I want to sell myself as being a
little more than I really am.
I want to be bill plus 20 percent.
And you want to say yourself as a little
more than you really are,
because we know that we're not fully
going to test each other because there's
negative consequences for testing and
whenever this negative consequences,
even for the winter for testing,
there's a lot of posturing that's going
to go on and that posturing is something
that's literally built into our psyche
and we go through life trying to sell
from flight on average.
Not already does this,
but on average trying to sell as much as
we can in order to gain the things in
life that we might not get if we're
brutally honest about what our
capabilities actually are.
Fascinating that we cling to all of
these ancient structures that are in
place when it comes to the way we
interact with each other and how
important is the social exchanges that
we have and that I think this is one of
the reasons why we cling to ideas so
much that these ideas,
if you can push an idea through,
you've got some sort of points
board.
Yep.
Got points on the board and probably
your ideas on average are going to
benefit you and my days on average
benefit me and so if I'm,
if I'm happily married in a monogamous
relationship and I'm not looking around
within monogamy's,
the great thing and sleeping around is a
sin,
but if I'm,
if I'm single and I've got
opportunities,
well then I probably hold alternative
views.
So on average our views not perfectly,
but on average our views serve as well
and if I can plant my views in your mind
and I've benefited.
yeah,
I saw that a lot.
I mean,
do you see that a lot with everything,
but I guess more what we're talking
about people that don't want to admit
like what about when it comes to like
pinker's data about the world being a
better place because they have almost a
vested interest in stirring up fear and
that they're committed in their mind.
They're committed to constantly studying
the wrongs of the world and the evil of
the world and that any sort of
diminishing of that is actually going to
cause harm to the people that are
suffering.
So I think they have a good perk in
their mind.
There's good intention,
I totally agree,
and the data are consistent with their
strategies because on average fear
appeals and anger appeals work a whole
lot better than,
hey man,
things are great.
Donate to this cause and we'll keep them
great.
That doesn't work at all.
It doesn't work at all.
And so when,
when viagra was invented in 1989,
my little brother and I were chatting
about it and we thought,
you know this,
I'll save some animals because there's a
lot of animals that are consumed for
their presumed potency affects by like
traditional chinese medicine consumers
and things like that.
And so we thought,
boy,
if I ever actually works prior to viagra
and nothing is out there that works up
at this 11 impact.
And so we wrote this little letter off,
send it to a journal and said,
you know that this is going to save
certain animals like seals,
which they could be harvested to eat
their penises.
Canadian seals.
I know a minute what?
I know people that you're allowed to
kill a certain number.
You can't kill the seals in America,
they're protected,
but in Canada,
us,
but in Canada you can,
there's a hood seal,
eliminate allow men and a harp seal
allotment,
and so people were killing up to their
allotments and selling.
You could do it solely for the penis and
sell the penis for enough money to make
your money back.
Now,
what purpose does the seals penis have
beyond the seals?
Original purpose.
Zilch.
Right?
But they eat it because it's supposed to
make you more potent,
satisfied as a rhino horn rhino horn as
an example.
That's used for lots of different things
so it's less likely to be helped,
but the seal penis is only,
you know,
people basically only using it for its
potency.
And then when fire comes along,
like literally you're shopping in the
supermarket where you could have by,
you're going to get,
I'll have some ceo peanuts or I'll take
a viagra.
Well,
we just said people are going to switch.
We were greeDy.
You throw both of them to try them both.
And.
And people did actually.
But,
but we,
we made this argument and we literally
were attacked by the world wildlife fund
government looking at plan to revive
seal peanuts.
What hold the fuck on is this recent?
It was updated,
was published in 2015,
but it was updated.
This may
what the government is looking at a
plan,
go back up to revive seal penis sales.
Okay.
This must be a plan was brought to the
government.
This must not be the worst way of like
looking at that headline is that the
government's thinking,
man,
we got to fucking revive these penis
sales.
No one's buying.
Because they actually may be thinking
that because you got some relatively
impoverished people are hunting for them
and no one's buying them anymore.
So if you're not going to.
Well,
if you're not going to reveal the report
drafted by the for institute.
Yeah,
there you go.
Aimed at creating new markets to support
an earlier proposal to kill a hundred
and 40,000
gray seals over five years in the
southern gulf of st laurence.
Seventy percent of gray seals that
frequent the area so that what they want
to do is they want to diminish the.
Okay,
here's what it is.
They have long complained that the
growing population of gray seals is to
blame for eating too many commercially
viable fish,
which has resulted in repeated calls for
a call.
Okay,
so they want to kill the seals.
So to save the fish market,
so they're going to get people to buy
dick.
Right?
So They make it financially viable.
Look at this.
This is racist.
The penises have juvenile adult animals
may be dried and sold as sexual
enhancement products,
particularly the asian buyers.
Well,
that's because it's not meant to be
racist is because in traditional chinese
medicine,
the seal penis was used as a potency
product.
I understand,
but the target,
those agents,
those poor fools,
but they're not portfolios anymore
because you know what?
They switched.
So we wrote this paper and literally the
world wildlife fund attacks tax us and I
did not see that coming.
Right?
I thought,
boy,
the world wildlife fund is going to be
psyched because here's some good news
for a change.
But they don't.
Good news,
they only
want bad news because people pay and
they do what they can to fix things when
it's bad news and they forget that you
got to have some good news along the way
or people give up.
Look at this list says here,
asian consumers,
particularly athletes also consume a
beverage called.
How do you say that?
Dallas shen oral liquid that is made
from seal penis and testicles,
which they believe to be energizing and
performance enhancing.
How about some studies?
motherfucker,
before you start eating sealed dick's,
try it.
See a.
No,
don't need that.
Check it.
Why would you take that one?
You can get fucking viagra.
Exactly.
Guarantee a viagra is better.
It is.
I mean if it's not better,
it's good enough.
Like what are you trying to do?
So.
So we actually,
because we got attacked by the world
wildlife fund,
we sent a,
one of my graduate student from Hong
Kong,
we descend them to go back to Hong Kong
for the holidays to go back to you.
The world wildlife fund,
because they said that were wrong.
people won't switch.
They say,
what?
How would,
how did they phrase it where they wrote
an article?
They rebutted us and they said,
no,
our data show,
when we tried to get people to switch
from ryan,
oh,
and tiger horn to aspirin,
they wouldn't.
And so they want sprint so they won't
switch to viagara.
And I'm like,
look,
I think fire is different from aspirin.
I got a headache,
I take an aspirin.
So yeah,
I think my headache got better faster
than it would have otherwise.
A little bit vague.
You need a viagra,
you take it.
You're like,
yep,
that sucker worked right.
There's visual evidence and so we argue
that it's different.
And so we actually went into these
clinics and we asked people in
traditional chinese clinics in Hong
Kong,
what do you take for a headache?
What do you take for gout?
What do you take for rectal dysfunction?
And that was the one case where they'd
switched.
So consumers all over the world,
they know when a pro,
a better product comes along.
They know when they've got no options.
Like what?
You might as well eat seals,
penis because that's as good as anything
or because nothing works.
Maybe you'll get a little bit of a
placebo effect or you know.
Oh,
hey,
look,
there's something that actually works.
That's what I'm going to buy.
What I read about the.
One of the issues with rhino horn with
some asian buyers is that also it's a.
It's a signal of affluence.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
It's prestige purchase,
so sad.
It is sad as shit ever because that is
such a crazy animal bizarre creature
that almost seems like a living dinosaur
it looks at and we're losing them left
and right now because people are killing
them for their fucking horn,
which just basically just collagen
fingernail.
Yeah.
It's bananas.
IT just doesn't make any sense to me
that that is still,
that they haven't realized that there's
no value in it,
that there's no physical value.
It doesn't really give you erections and
fever,
fever.
It's got to have a long list
unfortunately,
and then they're still buying it and
they're.
And they're buying it again for athletes
like they get a kick.
Exactly.
It's like buying a maserati.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
That's so sad.
Oh,
my daughter's outside the door.
Hi.
Get out of here.
You bothering us?
Um,
yeAh.
It's so strange to me that there are
these specific cases,
right?
Like,
it's not like people are looking for a
giraffe horns like funny is they're
looking for rhino horn.
Like what do you think that they made an
association like,
damn,
if I was jack liquor wine,
oh this chick's like,
man,
I need to get that horn and eat it.
And my dick get hard.
Like I do think so because if you look
at the long list of products,
they look pretty phallic and mostly
people he'd phallic things in order to
gain potency.
Is there something crazy about seal
dicks?
Like what's going on with decently
sized?
Decent.
A good word for that.
I like that.
And so you know,
you think,
oh that sucker,
I'll get big too.
Right?
We're so weird.
But it's so weird that in the face of
new evidence that people haven't adopted
this new evidence and they still clean
it.
At least some people claim to.
But here's the thing.
So our,
our pre modern ancestors didn't
understand germs at all,
right?
There was no way they could have.
It's such a bizarre idea that something
that small could kill you,
but they did know that if I touched you
when you were sick,
I might end up sick too.
And that seems almost like a magical
transference.
And if you accept this and they all know
that,
like they,
they'll,
they'll shy away.
We all evolve.
chimpanzees will shy away from
disgusting stuff and open source and
people really.
Yeah,
absolutely.
if you get the right kinds of illness
that,
that manifests,
that you're seriously outwardly sick and
contagious,
people find it disgusting.
And so that kind of magical contagion.
It's super easy to see why.
Well then it make you think that while
ryan and warren will make my dick bigger
too.
Yeah,
I guess,
I mean,
are there any instances where that stuff
is real where it does actually work that
way?
Not that I,
I can't think of any,
but it is the case that,
that you,
you being sick Will make me sick.
No question,
but nothing that like you eat and
animals thing you consume.
No,
but If it is the case,
imagine that,
that like after you and I chat you said,
hey,
bill here,
have my jacket,
and now I go out with your jacket on.
And people go,
oh man,
he's got joe rogan jacket,
he's cool and now I've got a little bit
of your cool and now the girls are like
me too.
LIke when hercules put the lion's head
on the head over and the lions thing on
it that you,
you kicked some ass to have that thing.
That's true.
Yeah.
I guess,
you know,
it's just,
we're so weird,
you know,
just uh,
the human animal itself is just such a
strange thing and the more you study it,
the more you go deeper and deeper into
the layers of weirdness that we are.
And psychology is pretty good about
finding out.
Our average weirdnesses were not so good
at finding out they're really unusual
weirdnesses because we can't predict
that one out of a thousand behavior very
well.
We can predict what people tend to do
when the bell curves tend to split.
We can't say what some random psycho or
genius or artist or whatever we'll do
under those circumstances because that's
not what our models are designed for.
You know,
it's um,
it,
it's so interesting when you think about
our interactions also with all the
various animals that we've come up come
across like all,
all throughout our,
our,
our life as human beings and that people
have chosen some to,
some to cherish and some to,
some to take on as food sources and some
to worship and,
and,
and often it makes good sense.
So dogs are great because we have great
vision though.
Our noses and ears don't work very well.
If we could have somebody around who
could hear and smell well and is on our
side,
that's a huge plus,
right?
It's worth feeding that thing or at
least tolerating it and they need some
scraps.
And some of them cats,
you know,
they're annoying.
They don't like you,
but they're good at killing rats and
other vermin that would,
once we were agriculturalists,
those kind of vermin would have been a
real problem.
They'd have been largely irrelevant when
we're still hunter gatherers,
but so we had dogs.
We domesticated those while we were
hunter gatherers,
but cat's the best I know is like
ancient Egypt and these,
these societies and in that storing
grain and things like that.
So those ancient systems make good sense
that you're making a deal with an animal
that can achieve something that you
can't achieve and of course you're
living in a world without chemicals and
machines and all that kind of stuff,
but tons of them are just totally
random.
And in this culture that thing is a
worshiped in this culture.
It's eaten and you know,
and that,
that sort of stuff is super hard to
predict.
Now in studying all this stuff and
writing this book,
how much has this changed the way you
just see humans?
Like as you're just going to the mall,
it does change it,
right?
So you see,
like I,
I remember being proud of my son when he
told a lie because I was like,
oh good I made and so we're in the,
we're in the playground and this little
boys playing with him and my son doesn't
have a lunchbox at all.
He doesn't own one and the little boy
says I got a spiderman lunchbox and my
son is like four,
four and a half.
And he looks at the kid and he doesn't
know spiderman.
It's because he hasn't seen the show
yet.
But he knows it's obvious.
The kids bragging.
It's obviously something good.
And he goes,
yeah,
I got a grasp man.
And a leaf man lunchbox.
Nobody.
He just made the shit up,
right?
Because spiders,
The spiderman or a grasp and he's
looking around for other things.
Right?
And so I was actually proud of it
because it showed a.
He's got theory mind down,
he knows what the kid can and can't
know.
And b,
he knows that telling these stories are
gonna be important for his place in the
social hierarchy.
So the kid looks at me and I'm like,
trying not to laugh,
right,
because I got to support my son and he's
like,
really?
And I'm like,
damn right kid.
And so you can imagine that it,
without this background,
you might say,
look,
we should discourage this kind of lying,
but it gives you a little bit of a
different perspective on it.
It also probably weird because you,
you know,
your kid realizes,
yeah,
my dad's got my back.
Like,
well that's good to know.
Thanks bro.
Exactly.
And then she'd always have your kids
back.
Yeah.
But grass man and leaf man,
you got to pull them aside.
Like,
dude,
you gotta come up with an animal to try
to do something that's got.
Well congrats man.
Actually do.
Besides photosynthesize by cow.
Exactly.
But he was on the spur of the moment and
he's only four.
So I decided it was good enough.
You know,
that that is also cattle worshiping is
very fascinating to um,
the uh,
like the hindus and all these different,
different tribes and different cultures
that were shipped cattle were other
people just thought of them as food
sources.
Right?
And so again,
now I don't know the origins that,
but you could imagine a system whereby,
well if you keep cattle and you benefit
from them rather than eating them,
you're going to get some gains from
that.
And we do know when you shift from being
a hunter
gatherer to basically kill in an eaton
stuff,
to being a pastoralist,
so your cattle or sheep or whatever or
to being a farmer,
you suddenly have to start taking on the
long game.
So humans are perfectly capable of
envisioning unfelt needs no matter what
kind of society they're in.
But hunter gatherers they're living for
today and so it's,
it's kill it,
you know,
hunted,
shared out amongst all of us.
And then we eat it and then we'll worry
about tomorrow when it comes along.
Well,
once you shift to having herds or having
land,
you can't.
That psychology doesn't work anymore.
And so what's super interesting is it
took literally like 10 or 20,000
years we've got the implements in place
to be agricultural is,
but we're not planting and it just,
we're just grinding stuff that we
gather.
And why did it take so long to plant
when maybe it was,
whether,
maybe it was a bunch of things,
but part of it is you have to shift your
psychology over and say,
all right,
I got to stop thinking about eating,
killing and eating it today.
I got to say,
well,
all right,
well would it be beneficial to me to
keep this beast around and have it for
tomorrow and drink it's blood or it's
milk or whatever.
And one way to get there might have
been,
well let's create a religion that says
we can't eat them today because that'll
solve it immediately.
Right.
That's one way to look at it.
But have you ever looked into some of
the other hypothesis on the origin of
cattle worship?
I think it again has to do with
psilocybin because.
Oh,
that could be too.
That'd be totally cool.
Grown cow shit.
And that'd be totally cool.
And not only that,
but it would because it has benefits so
like societies can do anything they
want,
right.
And there's some crazy systems that they
do in a lot of those are really bad
ideas.
There's sources of infection and disease
and death and those societies tend not
to grow,
but societies that do things that
happened to be good ideas,
even if they got it from mushrooms and
things like that,
those are going to really pass along.
And so you've got a lot of people on
this planet to worship cows,
which suggests that whatever got that
started actually probably had a benefit
because those societies grew and
worshiping god,
not something like when you come to me
and say,
hey man,
I worship cows and I'm thinking,
okay,
I,
I'd rather eat them,
but fine.
It's hard to imagine being persuaded,
but it's easy to imagine growing up in
that system over imitating,
right?
We talked about that.
You automatically just copy to add
warships,
cows,
things are working out well for him,
I'll do the same.
And then you've got.
And that's a good thing for your society
too because you can drink.
It's blood or it's milk or whichever
you're lactose tolerant,
whatever you do,
and then that allows you to society to
grow.
Was there anything surprising to you in
writing this book and researching it and
putting it together?
Was there anything that really just had
made you step back and go,
wow,
I didn't see that one common look.
There's a lot of things that I didn't
see coming and a lot of times where I
thought I had an idea of how it all
worked and then I thought I would read a
lot more papers and like,
oh,
that's not even possible.
They didn't have that capability or
whatever.
What surprised me was that I.
A big part of where this book comes from
is that then colleagues would say they
would know I'm working on this,
and they'd say,
well,
come give a talk at my conference on
leadership,
and I'd say,
well,
I don't know anything about leadership
nickel.
Well,
surely something.
It must have implications for that,
and every time they asked me to do that,
you know,
I'd say,
okay,
I'll give it a try.
And then literally you sit down and you
think about it,
you realize,
wow,
there are important implications for
leadership or innovation or happiness or
sociality and I never saw them coming.
And so it was literally friends of mine
kind of forced.
I had one goal which is to just
understand social intelligence and how
did we become so socially intelligent
and the.
And that was where I started in friends
just kept asking me to look at other
things.
And every time I did there was an
answer.
Sometimes it was an answer that is
easier to find.
It seems harder to find,
but it was always there.
And what that tells me is that there's
really a lot of value in taking the
anthropology and the biology and putting
them together and saying,
all right,
where did we come from?
And now what can that tell us about who
we are today?
That's an interesting.
It's sort of a intellectual exercise to
write a different perspective on the
material that you're going over.
And if somebody forces you into a little
box,
like tell me what you know,
what's the influence on or what the
impact on creativity or what's the
impact on leadership or all these
different things just to give you a
different view.
Let's look at it from the left.
Let's look at it from the top.
So I'll get it from below.
And that's what's so fun about sciences.
You can say,
all right,
well let's see if it tells us anything
that either we already know is true and
now we could get new things that we
would know about it or if it tells us
something that we don't even know,
but that might explain the way the world
is and both of those are valuable
because then you can run off and try to
test them and a lot of dead ends.
I mean that's what science is all about,
but some of them will hopefully not be
dead ends and you have runoff and test
and say,
holy shit,
now I understand innovation.
Now I understand whatever.
Well,
what's interesting about this kind of
material is that it gives you,
to me as an individual,
it gives me insight in my own behavior
and I think it would do a lot of people
do all of us some real good if we had a
better understanding of what our
motivations are and how we got to this
point in civilization,
what we actually are,
you know,
I mean maybe it will or won't change
your behavior,
but at least it will give you some
insight into.
I totally agree.
And the thing is that when I find myself
getting upset because you disagree with
me about something trivial or even
important like politics or something and
it takes a second,
you got stumped.
Say,
hold on,
I don't have any privilege.
Access to the right way to do things
right?
And so the fact that you care more about
x and I care more about why it doesn't
mean that you're an evil person and must
be overcome.
It means that probably we ought to be
talking to each other and trying to find
a compromise solution that makes things
work best.
But there's this automatic instead I
think that you are evil,
absolutely with me.
And so the beauty of this kind of,
the more you know about this stuff in
the past and our evolutionary origins,
the more you know that literally we've
evolved to do that because if we didn't
do that,
we're screwed,
but now we don't need to anymore.
And so now we can say,
well,
hold on,
I'm a lefty and you're in my example.
You're a righty and we disagree about
this particular president,
but a fine.
Let's see if we can both agree on a goal
that will make both of us happy rather
than,
no,
you're evil and all I have to do is
overcome you.
One of the things that I've really tried
very hard from doing this podcast is to
not be attached to ideas and to do that
as an exercise.
And I think over the course of the years
I've been doing this,
I've gotten way,
way better at that,
but it's just so fascinating.
I encounter in the raw form,
like when I go to a party and I just run
into some guy who's a dad and he brings
something up and I tell them,
well,
that's not totally true because of this,
and then you see this.
The blood starts pumping,
the heart starts beating and they're
trying to look at some way you're wrong
and it becomes a personal thing.
It gets very,
very heated
and it's easy for all of us to do that
in my job and your job is the same.
It's to say,
okay,
is it time to abandon this idea?
Is there a time the defendant and when I
was young and an academic,
there was no way I was abandoning.
That was last quarter.
it was going to do is defense,
so you attack me and I marshall
everything I can and I try to attack you
back.
And it was some of my colleagues were
like,
hey man,
you know when you're wrong,
it's cool.
That's what science is.
And I'm like,
ah,
you're right.
You're right.
I've got to start.
And so now,
even though I love the give and take of
academics and I love to argue about
stuff I tried really,
really hard to keep in my mind.
Well what if what You're saying right
now is right.
Rather than trying to just attack it,
which is my automatic instinct to say,
well,
what is it that you're saying now might
be a value that I should actually be
incorporating and not trying to stomp
on.
Yeah.
And also just the ideas aren't you
exactly.
Your you and these ideas are just
something that you're tossing around
beach ball.
Exactly rIght.
And that's super hard to keep in mind
because everything that,
that we come to own,
we get attached to.
And if I tend to have my ideas because
they tend to make the world a more
hospitable place to bill.
And in a way I kind of do need to defend
them because if you convince me no,
the way the world should work is whoever
is strongest gets everything while I'm
stuffed.
And so I need to try to fight against a
lot of alternative views.
And,
and I have to overcome that in my effort
to find what the right answer is as
well.
So it's,
it makes good sense that our ideas are
like possessions,
that we have attitudes toward our ideas,
just like we have toured the objects
that we own,
that means something to us,
to our family,
to our group,
et cetera.
That all makes really good sense.
And the other side of that coin is if we
talking about the way things used to be
in a premedical world,
if you're the chances of you carrying
different pathogens and I carry is
reasonably high and if you infect me,
I'm screwed.
Now if you do tHings differently than I
do think so you eat this food and I eat
that.
Food was different.
Could actually be wrong from my
perspective because if I do what you've
done,
I'm like get myself sick because you've
adapted to that,
that thing.
And so we literally probably for good
evolutionary reasons,
came to view cultural ways of doing
things that are different as if they're
wrong.
Because that saved us,
that protected us from the kind of
pathogen vectors that you've gotten
adapted to,
but that I haven't.
That's fascinating.
So that this is almost like ingrained in
us.
Well,
as we've evolved to be this way and so
it's hard to undo that.
Do you think that with the access to
information that we're currently
enjoying that because there's so much
information now and it's so easy to get
to that perhaps there'll be more
instances of people not becoming
attached to their ideas and recognizing
that they are there.
They are separate the you are just to
thinking organism and what the facts are
and what reality is is just something
that's happening and you don't
have to be personally attached to it.
It's not a part of your identity.
I hope so because in an ideal world we
could have the things that were attached
to that don't really matter.
I'm an iphone guy and you're an android,
but who cares?
Right.
We cOuld argue about it.
It'd be silly and have time.
Exactly.
We could still be friends and all that,
and then we could win something that
mattered and know this,
this political strategy will make
everyone poor or sick or whatever.
Then We could be willing to change their
minds because in the end i think we've
got this evolved desire to latch on to
these things,
these ideas and values and um,
and products even and all that.
And so it'd be nice if we could do it
with the trivial and let the stuff that
really matters.
Guide rna by its accuracy.
Well,
it'd be also nice if that.
The stuff that we do with trivial,
it's,
it stays actually trivial because
there's so many people will,
I guess it goes with sports teams and.
but it also goes with like brands of
cars.
Like I've heard people say,
I've always been a ford guy.
Love for.
It's like,
okay,
yeah.
It probably reminds you of the ford your
dad drove or whatever I guess.
But it's like I would never buy a chevy.
I know.
Really never.
It's funny,
isn't it?
If the best fucking car was a chevy and
you have the opportunity to buy it,
you're like,
no,
no.
I'm a ford guy.
Like,
right.
What benefits?
It's some strange reason.
There's some weird motivation to stick
to your initial statements.
Yeah,
so I think it's like oliver wendell
holmes or someone who's had a foolish
consistency is the hoBgoblin of small
minds.
Right?
But we all have these consistencies
because part of the problem Is if I move
around with the wind,
you look at me as I'm a [inaudible],
right?
stand flop.
If I can't stand by what I believe in,
then you have no respect for me,
but what if you.
What if you.
What you believe in is incorrect,
right?
That's how you play into that.
That's where it gets real,
right?
So what you.
Obviously what you ideally want is,
here's my value structure and it's
unchangeable and then negotiable.
And yet when you show me that I'm in
that my attitudes are impeding my own
goals,
then I'm willing to change them to
achieve that value structure.
And I think the best politicians and
scientists and artists and comedians and
all the rest of the ones who can do
that.
Well,
yeah.
Well I like what you said.
Like here's my value structure.
This is,
these are my ethics,
these are my morals,
this is how I treat people,
this is who I am.
But all that other stuff is just
information.
Yeah.
It's all a means to an end.
And so some people care a lot about
loyalty.
Other people care a lot about fairness.
Other people care a lot about sanctity
and purity,
right?
There's different values that are
important.
All of the world.
We all care about them,
but some people wait one set more
important more than another set.
John hyde,
if you.
I don't know if you've had him on your
show,
he does this work and he's one of the
first people that push these ideas and
you can predict them by people's
politics and stuff like that.
And so if we all agree,
they all matter,
but the problem is then we get into an
argument where you tell me loyalty is
more important than I tell you,
fairness or harm is really important and
then we're never going to see eye to eye
and probabilities,
you know,
with two humans that are healthy.
That's an interesting discussion
because why do you think fairness is
more important and why do I think
discipline is more important than
fairness or education is more,
or whatever it is.
I think that when someone clings to this
idea that this is the most significant
aspect of human civilization,
that's always weird and it's hard when
they can't acknowledge other
possibilities.
Right?
And some,
and again,
all of these things are,
I hate to say it,
but they're like 50 percent genetic,
right?
Some of us are more openminded and some
of us are more closed minded and there's
probably good reasons to be that way
that made your,
that made you successful under one set
of circumstances versus another.
Because you know,
extroversion,
for example,
almost all people prefer extroverts or
introverts,
but extroverts are all sorts of risks
for disease because they're constantly
up in everyone's face and so an
ancestral environment,
so it was probably pretty costly to be
extroverted and you paid a price in that
introverts didn't have to pay when you
got sick,
but it's also like we gained so much
creativity and insight from introverts
course.
No,
but,
but at a social level,
extroverts benefit introverts might
benefit by then running microsoft and
being the greatest artist and all that.
And that's again,
as we talked about this earlier,
the beauty about being human is how many
different ways you can achieve the same
goal.
What are your thoughts on the influence
of epigenetics?
Look at super interesting.
So my,
my.
I know little about it,
very little about it.
My behavioral genetics colleague insist
that there's no good evidence among
humans for multigenerational epigenetic
effects.
We know that they exist now in some
animals.
We can do the experiments pretty easily
to get these multigenerational epigenic
epigenetic effect.
Explain to people what we're talking
about.
Yeah.
So epigenetics is basically you can turn
genes on and off in the simplest sense,
and so environmental factors will
matter,
like maybe when you're in utero there's
a famine and that's a common thing
that's looked at.
We'll look at that in rats,
for example,
will underfeed the mother when the
baby's in there and that causes the
baby's methylation of some of the jeans.
I don't understand the science of it at
all,
but the turn some jeans on and some
jeans off and so a baby of a of a mother
rat who was raised who is in utero,
when the mother was underfed will mature
more rapidly.
It'll eat everything that's not nailed
down and it'll have sex with lots more
rats than unregular than a rat that
wasn't,
that,
didn't have it.
Some other starved.
And the key thing is that makes good
sense because it's a way to respond to
times of famine.
Grow as fast as you can,
reproduce as quickly as you can because
you know reproductions of currency,
of evolution,
the fact that you exist and live is
trivial.
The fact that you passed on your genes.
That's what evolution works with,
so it's a great way to change with the
local environment and there's some very
interesting evidence that then those
effects are even in the next generation,
so the child of a rat that was.
That was in a mother who was underfed.
We'll also have some of these strategies
I think,
believe they find that in humans as
well.
We all have suffered from famine.
That's the argument,
but none of the data.
My behavioral genetics colleagues says
none of those data are robust enough.
It's sort of like some of the criticisms
you made of what I've said and you're
right,
the data suggests things that might be,
but there's lots of alternative
explanations so we don't yet know it
will get read as about longevity and
that there was some sort
of evidence that points to the
descendants of people who survived
famine.
They,
they live longer.
Right?
And so the question might be why.
So we know,
for example,
that if you're in utero,
during famine,
males are more likely to be aborted than
females.
When it gets really bad,
female fetuses are probably more robust,
but if you ignore that gender effect,
in all probability,
those fetuses that could survive in a
mother during feminine might just be the
more robust specimens.
Right?
and so you might just be calling out the
people who wouldn't have lived as long
and so it's super hard to,
you know,
you don't do experiments on these things
in humans.
You can do experiments in mice and rats
and,
and try to find these things out.
The downside is,
you know,
if you've read about a million cancer
drugs that are really going to help us
and then they disappear.
It's because it works in a mouse and it
doesn't work in us.
And the downside of these things is even
mice and rats differ from each other and
so,
and we're a long way from either of them
and so the epigenetic effects,
did they show?
There may be good reasons why we don't,
you know,
there's some real ethical questions in
regard to running studies like that on
human being.
Exactly.
We're going to have to develop headless
humans in a lab that have no soul,
that we could do tests on what we could,
but I actually think that what will get
really good at is the issue you raised
earlier and that is,
I don't know everything that's ever
happened to you,
but some day it'll be possible to know a
ton of that stuff and I'll be able to
rule out all sorts of alternative causes
and diet is a perfect example.
You guys talk about that a lot on this
show.
Well,
how do we know that this particular
collection of foods will actually do you
any good?
How do we know how well people are
sticking to it?
And a big part of those effects are
actually the psychological effects.
So protein is a really good example that
you know,
steve simpson argued in the early
nineties that if you started with locus,
that animals are motivated to eat as a
function of how much protein that
they've consumed.
And so the atkins diet was the right
idea,
but a misunderstanding of the cause.
It's just the protein.
We evolved to feel full.
When you get protein,
we didn't evolve to feel full from
carbohydrates and there's a host of
reasons for that and there's a host of
other effects that are going on at the
same time,
but the consequence of that is then when
people's diets move around,
you say,
oh look,
this diet is this affecting that one
doesn't,
but you don't actually know what they've
been doing because some diets are harder
to maintain and they're cheating more
whatever.
Someday we'll have much better evidence
and all of that.
You'll be wearing a device.
I'll know what you consumed.
I'll know which aisle,
an accelerometer on the wall,
everything that happened to you.
Well,
that's another interesting aspect of
genetics,
right?
There's one thing that we absolutely
knows that some people respond
differently to doris and other people do
and you know,
for some person a particular type of
diet is beneficial and perfect and just
locked in and other person.
That'd be horrible.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's weird.
You kNow,
across the species I find that with dogs
or.
But it it at an ethnic level.
That makes perfect sense because the
people who have been eating different
foods for a long period of time,
I have to adapt to that and of course
agriculture is only 12,000
years old total,
although we've been eating cereals
before that in lots of.
Didn't have it at all or only had it
very recently and so it's super hard for
some people eat grains compared to other
people to eat grains because they're.
They haven't adapted either diabetes
wise or all the other kinds of things
that it can cause it to go wrong.
Certainly with alcohol,
that's a giant fan.
Exactly.
And alcohol gets invented every time
someone invents agriculture because all
you do is you accidentally leave it
there too long and it ferments.
Right.
And so there's an argument that we
actually evolved to have a tolerance for
beer rather than a taste for it because
once we're in early agricultural
settlements for the first time ever were
crapping where we're drinking,
we're not moving on.
And so we found our own drinking water,
so beers literally safer to drink than
water,
low beer and wine,
low grade alcohol.
And so what the data said suggest what
people argue is that we evolved to
actually have a taste for it,
but,
but tolerance to it rather than a
distaste for.
Which makes sense evolutionarily.
Getting drunk with hippos running around
you can't be a good idea.
Also,
if you think about wine or,
or any booze the first time you drink
it,
it's discussed.
Yeah,
it's hard to develop a taste for it.
It's exactly right.
And so,
and lots of things that,
that way tabasco,
you know,
lots of these spices have antibacterial
effects so the mothers are given it to.
The kids were like,
on my mouth would be on fire if I want
some six year old canadian India or
something like that.
Initially why they added sabi to sushi.
That's what a lot of people argue.
And in fact,
as you work your way from the pole to
the equator,
you get more and more spices because of
course in Sweden there's six pathogens
and you've got salt and pepper in the
jungle and then africa,
you've got to get zillion spices,
garlic,
all of these things are super powerful.
Antibacterials,
oh,
that is a really interesting way of
looking at it.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Right.
Like Mexico,
very hot and spicy food.
Warm climate.
Totally make sense.
Yeah,
exactly.
And the same thing happens with the
profusion of religions and languages.
The closer you get to the equator,
the more languages you out in the world
religions,
yet because people start saying,
you know,
on the other side of the valley,
literally you could have a pathogen that
makes me sick and so I'm going to stay
away from you and by staying away from
you.
Over time we developed different
languages,
different religions.
Again,
back to Sweden,
whatever you got,
I got.
There's three things to have,
right?
And so you're not a risk to me and we
share the same language.
We intermingle much more readily and
there's more ethnocentrism is you go
close to the equator.
Wow.
To keep keeping apart makes good
evolutionary sense under those
circumstances,
but we live in a world where no one's
keeping apart.
Now we live in a world where it makes it
much,
much more difficult and you don't
necessarily least in our,
in our blessitt industrialized
democracies where we've got good
medicines,
at least for now,
they still work.
You don't need to anymore.
Right.
But we also have these crazy factory
farming setups that lead to the kind of
horrible super bugs that could kill a
million people.
We did it.
I remember when I first found that out
that most of the major flus,
like avian flu,
swine flu,
I didn't know why they were calling it
the swine flu.
And then I found that no,
it's from domesticated pigs and it's
somehow more of some jumps to humans and
why.
And that was the cost we paid with
agriculture.
so the first time we were starting to
get.
We're a cheek by jowl with a bunch
animals and agriculture.
I mean hunter gatherers eat them.
They,
the animal never lives long enough to
give you the flu.
Right?
Wow.
So everything,
you know,
there's always pluses and minuses when
you change how you do things and we,
you and I are really lucky.
We live in a time where all these great
medicines exist in,
they haven't become worthless yet and
now it's really a race against the
evolution of the bacteria and devising
new medicines that can continue to
defeat them because everything's
becoming treatment resistant.
Right?
That's how evolution works and and
that's just starting to happen.
And so now scientists have to work
double time to keep inventing new drugs
to stay ahead of the game with the
exception of some things that just for
whatever reason,
bacteria don't seem to be able to evolve
resistance to them.
Well,
what's fascinating to me is not just
scientists creating these vaccines and
all these different medicines to deal
with these diseases,
but the potential of shutting off genes
that potential of altering the human
genome and using things like whatever
the future version of crispr is going to
be to.
I mean they've already figured out a way
to stop certain diseases.
So those single gene things are great.
Remember with everything being so
apologetic,
you don't just want to shut shit down
willy nilly and so then really what
you're at,
the advantages,
the point you made earlier.
So my diet should be 60 percent protein
in your should be 15 percent or mindset
or more leafy vegetables in euros,
whatever,
and we'll be able to know that we'll
know how my guts going to respond to it
and how you're gonna respond to it.
Well that's one of the things that 23
and me actually does.
They do.
They do show like what foods you'd be
more likely to be allergic to and what
things would be most likely to be
attracted and that's a great start.
But what we really need is apologetic
scores that tell you how do you process
leafy vegetables,
how do you process fats,
how do you process all that stuff?
And so because you knowj,
genes account for most of our weight,
that's most of the variance in our
weather or obese or not,
but nobody was obese when you and our
kids have.
Tons of people are obese now.
So what those genes really are is genes
to sensitivity to something changing in
our environment.
Either activity levels of the foods
we're eating or how process they are or
how much carbs,
whatever we don't know.
But that's what we're actually
genetically sensitive to it because all
of us have the same underlying problem.
That evolution didn't really worry about
obesity because the problem was the
opposite starving and so we were not
really good at telling when we're full.
ANd there's interesting evidence that
suggests some really lovely studies that
show that really one of the key guides
of appetite was variety.
When you eat a lot less variety,
you're.
That's when your stomach tells you
you're full really much more reliably.
But as you add variety to your diet,
which everybody on earth can do now
while everybody's got any money on earth
can do now that actually you short
circuit the best mechanism we had to
tell us to stop eating.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
And now as an argument that people who
are experts on nutrition are,
are making about one of the more recent
diet plans that people are using.
The carnivore diet is that just eating
only meat and there's a lot of people
that are doing that and they're finding
that they're having all these like
really rapid decreases
in autoimmune diseases and rapid
recoveries from eczema and siberia and
I'll psoriasis and the people that are.
A lot of people are saying,
oh,
it's the meat.
Meat's great for me.
It's great for her and some nutrition
experts saying more likely this is a
calorie like you're,
you're at a calorie deficit and by
putting your body into a calorie
deficit,
you're almost like in a,
in a state of fasting and you're
decreasing your body weight because
almost universally all these people that
are that are talking about the positive
benefits of these diets,
these elimination diets,
and just eating one thing.
One of the things that they're showing
us,
they.
They lose a shitload of weight.
Right?
And so the thing is that I suspect
you're right,
that either they're cutting out what for
them is the perpetrator and who would
ever know out of the 4,000
things,
right?
Or it's literally the losing weight and
then hopefully they're taking
multivitamins to make it for all the
stuff that they're not getting.
Right.
Yeah.
I don't think they are.
A lot of them are not doing that.
It's really interesting.
I've been following it pretty closely
and I've had quite a few people on the
podcast,
including really intelligent guys.
Like Jordan Peterson is on this.
Oh,
he does he and salt.
Right.
And for me that wouldn't work.
Although I am,
I,
I meet in fruit basically and then very
little else about grief.
You leafy green vegetables.
I know I should but I don't like.
Um,
so I know I don't like broccoli.
Broccoli's edible.
Oh,
I know I should.
So I,
my,
my wife makes them and I'll eat a little
bit of it.
But like a little kid.
I know,
but in my way it's like these arguments
I have with my eight year old.
no,
I know.
And your year olds right now,
by the way,
it turns out there are genes that make
people find broccoli more disgusting and
more at more bitter versus less bitter.
Some people really have their tongue
says no,
broccoli is called the beat,
a little baby gene,
but the one thing I would say there's
this really lovely study done with that
nice mix and what they did is they fed
people a couple of different foods and
you try a few and then you eat one until
you're full and then when you come back
to.
I don't know if you know this work,
like paul rosin started with amnesiacs.
If you.
If I,
if you're densely in music,
so I talked to you.
I leave the room,
I come back five minutes later.
You don't know who I am because you've
got brain damage.
When I come back with lunch,
literally you'll eat a second lunch.
We have such poor mechanism that tells
us we're full.
We think we do.
We feel good.
I've had a great dinner.
I'm really full,
but we don't realize is that's really
driven a lot by the knowledge that we
just ate and so what rosin found when he
went back into he had eat lunch to your
fault.
He goes back and says it's time for
lunch,
and literally they all eat it again,
and so what's what's amazing about these
studies is then this follow up study,
what they did is they served amnesic or
control food people,
foods that they sampled and food that
they till their full.
So you sample potato chips and then you
eat a tuna sandwich and now I come back
to you and say if you're a normal,
and I say,
do you want to eat a potato chip?
Do you want a tuna sandwich?
If you're normally say,
well,
I just had lunch.
I'm not really that keen deed either of
them anymore.
If you're uneasy,
you say,
I don't want a tuna sandwich,
but yeah,
I'll have some potato chips and so you
don't even need to know you ate it.
And so your hunger mechanism is still
there,
but the fact is you've had a lot of tuna
sandwich and that's controlling your
appetite.
It's making you feel like you don't want
to eat it anymore.
And so in the same sense,
you go to a steakhouse,
you think,
boy,
I love this.
My favorite steak.
I could eat it forever and then you
finish it or not,
and then you think,
oh,
I'm stuffed and somebody goes desert.
Actually,
yeah,
that does sound good,
right?
Because now you're shifting and you're
eating something else,
and so I suspect that what guided our
ancestors was the fact they had no
variety.
What's for dinner was not a question you
ever asked.
Whatever dad killed him,
whatever mum dug up like there's two
things there.
Right,
and so you're going to gorge on the
meat.
There's not a vegetarian hunter gather
on the planet.
You when you,
when you're hungry everyday.
Everybody loves me.
It's not only whatever.
You can every loves it.
Every in every hunter gatherer society
meet is a big deal.
Someone comes home with a big kill.
It's a big deal.
When you can afford to be very well fed,
suddenly you can start to think
differently and even have different
preferences,
but you don't if you're a hunter
gatherer and so literally if they had
killed a giraffe,
you're just stuffing as much.
Draft me down the pipe as you can and it
makes sense for you to then evolve.
Okay.
You're going to get nothing new out of
the giraffe you eat other than you're
going gonna.
Pull it out the back end.
It's time to shut this dinner down.
Right?
But if you told me,
oh look,
we've got this other thing that's
helpful.
Well,
there's nutrients in that I don't
already have.
And so you could imagine getting hungry
again.
That's what they did to suggest.
Well,
it's interesting because that's kind of
the argument that these carnivore diet
people use is that that is the most
beneficial food because that's the food
that you look forward to the most,
the right,
but don't forget you only need to do
this within every meal.
So if you sit down for your favorite
lobster dinner just to have lobster and
then that doesn't mean emptied it for
lunch or for breakfast tomorrow.
Now you can have pancakes.
Whatever it is.
The key is within every meal,
minimize your variety because that's
where the effect is having itself.
It doesn't have to carry over time.
It doesn't mean you lobster every single
meal.
You know it's interesting.
That's actually the gracie diet.
There's jujitsu family called the grace,
started the ufc and world famous
brazilian jiu jitsu family,
but just a family,
philip killers and one of the founders,
I believe it was carlos gracie invented
this.
He invented a diet that was basically
you shouldn't mix foods together.
if you're eating fruits,
you should eat fruits by themselves.
You meet,
you eat that by itself,
and that in combining all these things
together,
your body produces a variety of
different enzymes.
You don't get as much nutritional
absorption.
Now that may be.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't understand the underlying bio
science,
but what I do know,
the psychology suggests that you'll stop
eating sooner if within any one meal you
have less variety,
so the psychological level we've we
appear to have evolved to not want that
anymore.
When we've had enough of that be it a
taro root or mom dug up or a giraffe are
dad shot,
so these sort of evolutionary traits
that are
inside of our bodies,
they would.
They would sort of encourage us to eat
much more if we have a variety of
different foods.
If you're eating at a buffet in vegas,
yeah,
versus if you just eating chicken,
that chicken,
you'll eat as much chicken as really you
need and then you'll stay.
I don't want any more chicken,
but if there's chicken mashed potatoes
and corn
on the cob and then cole slaw and our
ancestors never faced that prompts the
date.
We don't know how to deal with it and
the other side of that coin.
So what steve simpson did,
this guy who did the early study on
protein and locus,
he,
he took his biology students on field
trips and he would talk to the food to
increase the protein in the food or
decrease it in the food,
but it's the exact same foods like to
read in the same roles in the same
sushi,
but he's increasing levels of protein in
those foods and then it's a buffet and
all he does is weigh the food when it
starts and when it finishes across all
the students eating it and he found that
as the protein levels go up,
the amount of food that people eat at
the buffet goes down.
So there's these two parallel
mechanisms,
one were made of protein and so that
seems carbs do drive appetite,
but not nearly as strongly as proteins
do.
So you,
the tolerance and how much courage to
lead is huge.
The tolerance,
how much protein.
Juliet is very narrow and he finds out
of course,
when he finds that in crickets and now
he finds it in humans.
And then I think the other side of that
coin is,
is variety.
And the bad luck for us right now is we
live in a world where,
especially if you're poor,
proteins are expensive and hard to get.
So you're going to have these high carb
diets and then everybody can have
variety and variety is probably a really
bad thing that is so fascinating is that
are our good fortune is our demise.
Exactly.
And in so many ways,
I mean,
you know,
we evolved to seek out fat,
sugar and salt because they were in
short supply another every.
Now you,
if you eat them every time you see them,
you're stuffed.
Right?
They're everywhere,
man.
I mean everything you eat as fat,
sugar and salt.
Exactly.
And then the other,
it's not just what you eat.
We also evolved.
So if there's a novel per person in the
opposite sex,
it comes along.
Boy,
what a rare event that was.
Maybe fat.
sugar.
Exactly.
You should jump on that train,
right?
Because that'll give you a new genetic
opportunities,
but you look out the door,
there's novelty everywhere.
it's super hard.
It's hard to stay married in the city
than it is in the country.
It's hard to stay married if you're a
celebrity than if you're a nobody.
Because those people are just dev
novelty constantly.
They have variety constantly.
And the rest of us,
well you know,
there may be variety out there,
but they're not interested in me.
So it's kind of irrelevant.
Anyway.
All right bill,
thank you so much.
I can't wait to read your book.
Excellent approach for everybody.
It's available right now.
Go get it.
You.
Fox is awesome.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Really fun.
A lot of fun.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.
That's amazing.